Donald Trump is facing 561 years in
prison in fact he's fundraising off of
it not surprised his betting odds have
increased with these latest indictments
and the betting odds for his rival
candidates are going down well again I
can't say I'm surprised because whenever
they go after Trump like this he's going
to raise tons of money they put his name
in The Press they make historical
context by which Trump will raise
historical sums of money
this will be interesting Alan dershowitz
came out and said that scotus will shut
this down and uh I he's probably right
some people some people are saying that
it's going to go to the Supreme Court
before it even sees any kind of
arraignment or criminal trial but we
shall see in other news this is
interesting Vivek ramaswamy is getting
roasted because he said he doesn't
believe the 911 Commission report of
course he is completely correct in his
opinion and how he broke it down and the
media is taking this tiny morsel
slightly out of context to try and smear
him but I find that one particularly
funny and then um I guess because
everybody wants to have a good laugh and
you know we're always talking about this
negative news world war three you know
Poland is saying that the Wagner group
is headed towards a NATO country and all
this stuff we're gonna talk about
something a bit more
positive that'll make you laugh and feel
good Justin Trudeau is getting divorced
uh okay he's not really getting divorced
separating from his wife but we'll see
how that plays out and then we got a
bunch of other stories we'll probably
talk about lizzo you know she's getting
sued because she like mercilessly abused
her backup dancers and it's like truly a
horrifying story there's a bunch of
other stuff we can get to before we get
started my friends how to
head out of brew.com and bye cat brew
coffee this is this is our coffee
company we are sponsoring ourselves so
when you buy from casper.com you're
helping support this show we got a whole
bunch of really awesome new Blends we've
got Mr bocus pumpkin spice experience
rise with Roberto Jr we got standier
grounds our medium roast is now back in
stock officially sleepy Joe decaf you
guys should just buy that one because
sleepy Joe is the name and it's it's
hilarious but uh support the show by
going to casper.com don't forget to go
to timcast.com click join us become a
member to support our work directly and
as a member you get access to the
uncensored members only shows Monday
through Thursday at 11 p.m I'm sorry 10
p.m and we're going to have a uh members
only show tonight at 10 pm and you will
be able as members to call in and
actually talk to us and our guests so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this share with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Tower gang Jose
hey yeah thanks for having me I'm
looking forward to it uh I'm Jose
garisson I have a podcast called no way
Jose I'm probably best known for my
coverage on the Oklahoma City bombing
last time I was here I let you guys all
know that Terence hiki didn't kill
himself and less than a month later CNN
ended up covering that story so today
I'm here to tell you can't surrender
didn't kill himself and Jesse trying to
do his brother sure could use some
awareness he's still continuing his over
25 year long Battle For Justice and his
brother's death and the people that did
him in you know still walking free today
I have no idea the context of uh it's an
individual in the Oklahoma City bombing
I suggest people go look into it type
search up can't thread to do if you'd
like to get a shirt use no way Jose at
checkoutlobster.com 15 off just for the
show uh yeah I'm also on Tower gang
which an offensive comedy podcast so
both my podcasts are very different but
uh yeah I'm looking forward to being
here today uh um thanks for hanging out
we got a Hannah Claire bremelo hanging
out hi I'm Hannah brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com
follow them on social media and Brett's
here oh yes hello my name is Brett
dazovic I am the host of Pop Culture
crisis Monday through Friday 3 P.M
Eastern Standard Time glad to be here
yeah Ian is out because uh he's been
he's been working out so aggressively
that he is currently drained and laying
on the floor downstairs my favorite part
is now when he's walking around he's
walking around in cut off shirts yeah
that's that's the best part he's getting
ready I love it
oh yeah it's a good singing you Ian it
really has uh he's like his whole
personalities kind of shifted a little
bit I think you guys would agree it's
the testosterone that's charging through
his veins you know it's that he's he's
bulking up I saw him punch a hole in the
wall the other day he bumped my
shoulders on the way up here at it man
yeah yeah anyways uh search.com guys uh
let's get into whenever you're ready to
him all right here's the first story
from midi I
561 years in prison Trump fundraising
off of recent indictment with dire
warning you could be thrown in jail for
six lifetimes
so I actually got this email and uh it
says Patriot with crooked Joe's corrupt
doj heading unlawfully indicted yours
truly yet again reports indicate that I
could now face a combined 561 years in
prison from the left witch hunts six
lifetimes there's only one message
someone can send by trying to throw you
in jail for six lifetimes and that's
fear
the fear that if you vote for the only
candidate who puts you first you two
could be harassed indebted and even
arrested by the current Marxist regime
in Washington
all right well so we know about these
indictments but the latest update here
aside from the fact that Trump could be
facing 561 years Alan dershowitz says
conviction of Trump would be overturned
by the Supreme Court
on Tuesday Biden's doj filed yet another
indictment this we know following the
announcement lawyer and Harvard
Professor Alan dershowitz sat down with
Fox News Sean Hannity discussed the
former president's legal prospects
suggesting that while he would likely be
convicted the ruling would be overturned
by the Supreme Court quote they claim
that Donald Trump actually believed that
he lost the election that everything he
did was fraudulent that he conspired
with unnamed lawyers to affect the
election you're allowed to challenge
elections indeed the best way to
challenge elections is to come up with a
slate of alternate electors the
government has the burden of proof
Beyond a reasonable doubt that
subjectively Donald Trump actually
believed that he lost the election and
acted contrary to that belief there is
no Smoking Gun there is no one who is
credibly prepared to testify that Donald
Trump said to him I know personally I
lost the election
what they're doing the indictment is
they're taking things where Trump said
like you're crazy to someone as if to
imply that means he really knew that he
did lose the election but more
importantly I'm not so sure how much any
of this procedural stuff matters what
the Democrats have been doing is
effectively just an onslaught of
whatever they can keep firing off at
Donald Trump and it's probably going to
be some kind of Death By A Thousand Cuts
yeah it's impossible not to factor in
the timing here right like you've had
these investigations going what since
the day he was elected like he has been
so uh intensely investigated for the
last effectively eight years and now all
of a sudden on the eve of an election
they they are ready to uh prosecute they
have all of these ideas in fact they
aren't just going to try it in one Court
they're going to try it three different
times I mean it's sort of bizarre uh
Mike Pence said yesterday you know I'm
gonna wait to review everything but this
is just a distraction from the real
issues Mr Trump under the bus he threw
him under the bus and he's not even at
last I checked he didn't even qualify
for the debates right like I think this
shows you how intensely influential the
Trump campaign is that they are timing
Federal investigations to try and throw
off his his campaign I mean this is one
of the things that comes up when are
they going to have these trials right
will it keep him from basically
campaigning and being with people and
instead it'll be in the headlines where
you know they're going to restrict media
access to the court they're gonna all
these issues just to try to slow him
down and nothing is working yeah it's
like the same old Tire Trope they tried
this with Russia and kind of bog him
down over and over again and now they're
continuing I just I don't know at what
point will they pull a different play of
their playbook I'm a little concerned He
Is straddling the line like kind of JFK
ish like at what point does he hop over
the line to where the you know the Deep
state does something I don't know and
what are they gonna do I I don't know
it's always a possibility for any
president for a variety of reasons but I
don't think that's the route they go I
think what's more likely to happen well
for one they tried the rape thing in New
York where they're like he's been
convicted by or not convicted he's been
found liable or something for some 30
year old nonsense story I just want to
stress how ridiculous and insane the
story was and if you believe it you're
oh well if you claim to believe it
you're either lying or really dumb that
Trump went into the what was the
department store like this murder of
good Goodman right yeah yeah this
massive department store and for some
reason nobody was anywhere they walked
in and everyone just vanished they must
have been raptured because they were
gone and then they went into a dressing
room where for some reason the doors
were unlocked and then they went inside
did the deed and left and no one noticed
a sink no noticed no one noticed the the
King of New York the most famous guy in
the city nobody noticed him walk into
this massive shopping center it's an
insane story but they've they've tried
that I bring that up because this is
what they did to Julian Assange they
made this ridiculous fake story about
first it was like a condom bro and then
molestation then the media reports it as
rape which is all a lie then they throw
it all out and say yeah that's nonsense
we don't care about that anymore now
they're going after him for Espionage
which is also nonsense
but Hillary Clinton was famously quoted
as saying can't we just drone this guy
and then they were like yeah he's in
London so no we can't but this is
typically what they try to do to people
outside of Western Nations inside
they've changed strategies they don't
make a martyr of these people so what do
they do they accuse Julian Assange of
being a rapist so that it sounds really
really awful historically and in the
Press they try that with Trump but it
seems to just bounce off because nobody
cares and nobody believes it anymore
people have already picked their sides
right like you're not you're not going
to convince anybody that hates him that
much that he's that he's a good guy and
you're not going to convince the most
entrenched of his fans that he's
suddenly a bad guy even if even even
many of us fans don't see him as that
good of a guy well it's it's more so
he's a sword
he's or what did Michael uh what did the
um Michael Moore say a human Molotov
cocktail so when they come out and they
throw all this garbage at Trump to stick
to him and they're like see look how bad
he is they're like oh you're tweeting in
the pot and I think it's hard to
contrast Trump who hypothetically did
something after we demanded he turned
over all of these documents under he's
he's been under Federal scrutiny for
years with the actual reality of the
Biden Administration right like when you
are comparing two things the effects of
inflation on your family and
hypothetical goose chase which actually
is the federal government wasting
taxpayer funds I feel like I'm gonna be
more mad at the federal government
overall it's not helping whatever cause
they think they have so the question is
are they indicting Trump to interfere in
the election
to distract from the Joe Biden
corruption allegations or could it be
that the U.S credit rating was just
downgraded from AAA to double A Plus and
we've had a I I think the highest number
of bankruptcies in the first two
quarters this year in the past since the
past 13 years so something is going
wrong economically inflation is through
the roof I mean just go to the grocery
store buy groceries and and and it's
nuts so there was a viral Tick Tock
where it was like this couple and they
were like it said buying grocers in 2011
and they're like dancing and they have
this big table it's like a hundred
dollars and then it was like buying
groceries today and they're standing
there and there's like five things and
it's the same price so yeah when middle
working class and middle Americans are
right now watching the news and someone
on CNN comes out and says Donald Trump
had classified documents they're like
I'm just trying to buy some beef for my
family dude I don't know I don't know
what you're talking about yeah meanwhile
561 year it's giving very Alexander
desperate it's giving Alex Jones what
does he owe now like two billion dollars
or like no wasn't it it's like a
trillion dollars like he's he's just
going it was the GP of France wasn't it
the entire European nation like it's
it's like they just throw the book at
them because they hate them they
understand that the people that already
hate them are going to continue to hate
them they're like oh good even though
they understand that he's just gonna
file bankruptcy and whatever's gonna
happen and what happens my thing is like
all of this seems like a politically
charged goose chase when there are like
actual child Predators or you know
murderers out there who get less time
yeah it was it was 2.75 trillion that
seems a reasonable that's the GD the GDP
of France I like the idea Alex Jones
must pay us the GDP of France he's like
yep I'm on it it would be funny if like
everybody in France loved Alex Jones at
the point where they were buying from
him and he did make that much money we
just didn't know about it and they just
asked for his demo they're like we've
got you don't worry but also like I mean
there's j6 people like they're gonna
Rush this trial to make sure that it
happens like right before the election
meanwhile j6 people no trial no nothing
it's it's very like if you pay close
enough attention to what's going on in
the world you understand just how unfair
all of it is but the average person is
getting that close attention that's what
I found weird about Pence's comments
because he released this statement like
right after the indictment came out
being like it means more talk about
January 6 and other distractions and you
want to be like we should talk about
doing sex we should talk about Genesis
all the time because there are people
who were persecuted in a way that no one
else has been and we just let them fall
to like we you shouldn't let them just
fall the Wayside like that's the best
thing about the Trump uh Trump situation
in my opinion which is that we like
continue to talk about the miscarriage
of Justice at the federal level wasn't
it like literally the day before January
6 Mike Pence said we're gonna have
Congress go through this and we're gonna
hear the evidence and the next day he's
like yeah no I'm not gonna do that I'm
willing to bet that like that night he's
in bed with his wife and there's like a
knock on the door and he's like whoa
who's the guy who wakes up at two in the
morning and then he comes to the door
and there's a guy in a suit with like
Black sunglasses and then the guy and
Mike's like what's going on and then he
just hands on a picture of JFK and then
Mike's like
okay I really just feel like it was just
politically expedient from the time it
wouldn't I don't think anyone needed to
say anything he knew that his role as a
vice president at time was to kind of
tacitly be in this in between spot it
was very clear too and that's why
there's so much rage from the Trump base
against Pence is because they kind of
knew he was talking about both sides of
his mouth and he didn't really mean all
this like him saying that oh we'll look
into this what does that even mean we'll
look into it okay cool like that doesn't
mean much of anything this is a big
component too of the of the suit now
because it's being reported the uh
what's what's a guy's name Smith what's
his name Keith Smith Jake's the is it
Jack Smith Jackson special prosecutor
whatever that he claimed that uh Pence
did not have the authority to reject
electoral votes which is wrong
he absolutely did until 2022 apparently
there was some revision to the law but
uh Democrats famously uh brought
together an alternate slate of electors
from Hawaii in 1960. despite the fact
that the state was won by the
Republicans the governor certified the
Republican electors Democrats still
convened a fraudulent slate of electors
I say fraudulent good sir
and uh because if they claim about Trump
and then sent them out and Nixon chose
to ignore as vice president he ignored
the certified electoral votes and said
I'm gonna count the Democrat uncertified
votes anyway well hold on how does the
vice president have the authority to do
that back in 1960 and then lose it well
I suppose Congress could change things
but that's not what happened Mike Pence
did have this Authority Trump's lawyers
were advising him not perfectly but he
had he had some sound uh a policy and
and procedure advice and then Mike Pence
was just like
screw it yeah I'm out it seems crazy to
me also you know like I said before I
don't think he at last I checked he had
not qualified for the debates which
debates our questionable anyways uh the
strangest thing about this is he has to
walk this weird line that's like
well I was part of the Trump
Administration and that's literally why
all of you know who I am except also I
don't really want to be affiliated with
the bad stuff or the more controversial
stuff so I'm going to sort of be the
most politician politician of all times
and try to make everyone happy in which
I will fail the the crazy thing is that
Mike Pence threw Trump on the bus
tweeting that this but basically saying
this man should not be allowed to be
president or whatever it's the inversion
of the fake ramaswamy when Vivek came
out and said we should all come together
and reject these political indictments
and these charges they're trying to
remove Trump you know in an unjust way
that's really amazing so when you when
you say that Mike Pence doesn't qualify
for the debates there's there's it's not
a very difficult question as to why well
it's because he hasn't got enough donors
that's like literally what I'm referring
to yeah nobody wants to give money to a
guy who sucks yeah but that's so
interesting right because theoretically
at one point he thought he was The Heir
Apparent like if Trump got two terms he
would be the next obvious candidate to
win and like he made such a catastrophic
miscalculation and then continue to be
like I think I can do it I think I could
win I think the landscape has changed so
much I said a minute ago that what Mike
Pence was doing was politically
expedient but that was kind of wrong it
was traditionally politically expedient
right and they're still in that mindset
what is now becoming the type of
rhetoric that is becoming actually
politically expedient is things like
what Vivek is is saying like actually
owning it and having bold messaging and
having a legit message I mean I am a
little bit concerned about some of his
messaging and from the past but some but
I I don't know I'm open to see maybe
just change his mind but I mean either
way that is the rhetoric people want let
me pull this up from predict it this is
the the latest prediction numbers Vivek
ramaswamy tied in second place with Ron
DeSantis and uh you know I think he
might he might overtake Ron DeSantis in
the uh it's for second place very very
soon
When Donald Trump gets indicted Vivek
comes out with a very very strong and it
seemed unscripted message about how this
is wrong
whether or not you trust Vivek he is
he's rolling 20s he is he is hitting all
of his marks he's responding
authentically and properly he's
answering the questions when people
criticize him he tackles them head on
now he is rising in the prediction
market so I suppose we shall see at what
point he hit second place but uh I'm
already seeing a ton of trump supporters
saying that if for some reason Trump was
completely incapable of running Vivek
would be their guy
it's definitely interesting he sent out
a couple uh fundraising emails this week
saying I am on track to overtake uh Ron
DeSantis and when he was here the other
week he was saying like we were hoping
to read about reach about a 10 in the
polling by the end of the year we're we
are much farther ahead of that his
campaign really has had a lot of inertia
behind it what do you guys think what do
you think uh I know I think Vivek will
take him over I think Ron is plummeting
and I'm kind of heartened by it because
uh I heard you guys on the show the
other day saying vivik's kind of like a
a right-wing Obama and I I it's funny my
buddy Reed Coverdale actually said the
same thing about Ron at one point where
he was kind of following a similar kind
of thing but it's it's almost like the
people kind of saw it because I'm of the
opinion that I mean maybe Ron would be
great when he got in but I I'm sensing
neocon Vibes so it really feels like no
no Ron so I'm saying like he kind of was
the right wing Obama but now it's like
it's kind of that idea was like
traditionally politics being or modern
political experience now it's like Vivek
could be that right wing Obama to where
it's like I don't know maybe he will
swap when he gets an I don't know maybe
he'll stay true to BJ he is genuine I'm
I'm unsure but he seems pretty genuine
from every time I've seen him talk but
point being is it's just I'm heartened
by the idea that people kind of lost
faith in the wrong thing like I love to
be clear I love him as a Florida
Governor I think he's great but now when
you get the reins of federal power
that's a different story now you're
controlling foreign policy Vivek is he's
going on every show and just saying ask
me yep and it's just raw unfiltered and
authentic it's it's masterfully done
whether he's you like him or trust him
or not if if he is being duplicitous and
political and trying to earn votes he's
good at it he he's yeah he's the best
I've ever that's the scariest part right
it's the ones who are really good at it
that's the ones you have to worry about
is the ones who are really really good
at hiding it until the last moment right
and he has done a very good job about
that because I think anyone who has even
base level political knowledge sees him
and sees some type of comparison to
Barack Obama but I would also maybe
posit that people who are now paying
attention to politics especially of
people who lean right are far more
informed on these issues so if he's
going to fool them it will be a lot
harder to fool them than to fool a
political novice in 2008 you can't just
put up a hope post uh you know a hope
and change poster and call it a day yo
uh uh Viking vet told us to he super
chatted saying pull up the predicted
graph and you can actually see the fake
has already surpassed a santis on on one
occasion I think if we let's go back 30
days we can see that uh yeah there is a
period where uh Vivek and DeSantis had
tied and then on the 28th Vivek actually
surpassed DeSantis by two cents and held
that uh lead for I believe two days so
they tied in and now it's it's going
back up so he's already gotten it I
think uh
I think the story of Vivek is that he
was very much
apolitical he was kind of just like
somewhat political and then the story he
told us was that when the when the BLM
riots happened people came to him and
said change your company's profile
picture to the black square and he was
like oh sure whatever and he does
when they come to them and they're like
now write a letter about why what
happened was bad and he was like yep
sure I guess and then he writes like hey
the writing is really bad it's
unfortunate what happened I hope this
country can come together and heal and
they were like no no you're supposed to
be why we're right and support us and he
was like okay now you're pissing me off
like I I I wrote something then he
started getting board members from his
company resigning it seems like Vivek
was this
successful what is he worth half a
billion dollars is running a
pharmaceutical company minding his own
business probably very pleased with
himself at 37 and then woke activists
started attacking him
and look it's one thing if you're like
an indie game developer or a small
YouTuber or a random guy who works at a
steel mill and they're coming to cancel
you it's another thing if you're the guy
who founded a multi-billion dollar
pharmaceutical and you're worth half a
billion dollars and they come at you and
try to cancel you and then I'm just
imagining him sitting there like
clenching his fist being like I will
destroy you and now this is the story he
told that like after seeing that he
realized how dangerous this stuff was he
wrote the book I think what capital he
started talking about ESG being a
problem he created a a
um I wasn't a mutual fund he created a
fund I'm not I'm not a finance guy
specifically to reject what's going on
with ESG and all that and then he's like
I'm gonna run for president so that this
dude's just just he's doing an amazing
job he's nailing it I'm a big fan he
seems to be fitting in more like with
the well-informed voters who would
naturally vote Trump you would have
thought they would have gone towards Ron
because he was such a culture War issue
type guy but those issues whether we're
talking about financing from companies
like BlackRock or Vanguard pushing back
against that type of cons of ESG based
capitalism is going to be strong for him
because the people who would vote for
Trump if he was out of the election are
going to care about that stuff and Ron
can't seem to land much of it we did a
clip the other day where he's like at
like some meet and greet with people and
he just laughs really awkwardly and
walks away and it's just like he can't
win like he like the clip is bad it's
not even his fault in this case right
but somebody's poison it just seems
awkward and the the dude can't catch a
break honestly I found an endearing
personally because I'm like no that's me
yeah but like right now he's in like he
he's facing people who are very much
antagonistic right so that's going to be
that's not going to be shown in a way
that's endearing to people like certain
people might see it that way like you
said you you identified with it because
I would I would be that way you know at
the party too but in general that's not
something you want in the the leader of
your of your military right I think I
think what's cool about vivek's
messaging is that it's more than just
like you know Rhonda Sanders did a lot
of really interesting things culture
your worldwide especially when it comes
to gender ideology one of the things I
like about vivek's campaign is that it's
much more about the renewal of like
Civic engagement and about patriotism
and about values that bring us together
and I think as much as like the more
divisive aspects of the culture War are
definitely worth fighting it is nice to
also say like here is actually what we
want instead of just saying well we
don't want these things what do we want
and I think that's cool there are
definitely stuff about like the campaign
that I don't personally agree with I
think there should be more restriction
on legal immigration he doesn't but I am
grateful that he's on the scene because
he's provoking a lot of really
interesting conversation I would
describe Donald Trump's campaign in a
single word
Revenge I I don't see a lot more I mean
he's fundraising they're coming after me
they want to destroy me and strike fear
and I'm fighting for you and I see all
of this and I'm like Trump wants to go
in there and get revenge I like it
someone's got to go in and and have a
beef to just start firing the
bureaucrats and that's a great first
step towards fixing the problems in
government not all of them you know
government itself is a problem in many
ways and then you have Vivek ramaswami
and I look at him and you and and if I
were to describe his campaign it's like
you said Civic engagement he's talked
about Civics tests for voting he's
talking about
um American values and things like this
and he's he's he's nailing it
my question for you guys I guess how
would you describe Rhonda Santos's
campaign like his policies what he's
pushing what he stands for what
represents like what does he represent
he's just not picking something he's
trying to be this essentially the of
Avec in a sense or like some sort of
Vivek you know Trump but he's not really
well I just mean the vibe like and then
he's but he's not really committing he's
also still kind of like sort of like
being like Oh to what like Elite talking
points kind of like eluding a little bit
but I might still be for that like it's
like there's so many things like I don't
want to use waffling I think on the
Ukraine stuff a while but he was talking
about it and he was just kind of like
can you really just not say no like just
we're done like and none of this like oh
we need to have a presence here and then
like just none of this like politician
talk people are over it they want you to
be solid about what you want and like
take a strong stance I think he has this
pull between his like Ron with his base
and his donors I think that is kind of
what the issue is so he's like where do
I go and it's like you got to pick one
or the other I mean preferably the base
how was it hard though I mean what
single voter actually is is voting for
more money being sent to Ukraine
maybe like Ukrainian Americans the
donors somebody who has a connection to
Ukraine yeah the thing is I felt like
Ron DeSantis was the strongest when he
was just around DeSantis in Florida
thinking about Florida doing what he
could for Florida and he didn't have
what I assume he now has which is this
kind of what you're talking about like a
donor class that's come in and say okay
this is what we think will translate
best to the National level and in that
way he's lost his sense of self which
like you're saying when you have strong
contenders who have these personalities
their campaigns have a rhythm they have
sort of found found their their Niche uh
in terms of the interview circuit it's
very different than sort of where Rhonda
Sands is right now and again that's not
to say that he doesn't ever have any
interesting talking points or anything
like that but you start to feel like he
is not catching the Rhythm that he needs
to to sustain his second place standing
that's unfortunate man
I feel uh I feel let down yeah the uh
that uh video you guys have been talking
about a lot recently I think was a
perfect example where like they're
trying to sort of which one the the one
with the Ukraine or the stone whatever
the heck it's called yeah yeah which
personally I thought was awesome but
like obviously no not I don't think the
Nazi said the video the whole vibe of
the video it was like how do you
accidentally put a spinning black sun
behind your candidate with with soldiers
marching towards it that's not an
accident yeah and if you're gonna do it
if you're gonna do it you need to own it
you probably shouldn't do it but if
you're gonna do it you shouldn't you own
it just be like hey it was a cool symbol
there it's stupid trying to own it but
trying to do this in between thing where
like our people put it out and we're
trying to have this plausible
deniability it's just silly either do it
or said I don't know I saw from the
Ukraine Fighters yeah so that we that's
what it was all about solidarity yeah
let's uh oh you know Ian's gonna be
really upset he's not here tonight
because we have this story from Politico
Vivek ramaswamy quote I don't believe
the 911 Commission report the GOP
candidate went on to insist he was
expressing doubts about the Saudi
government's explanation for the attacks
let me just say first and foremost you
want to talk about honesty in a
political candidate have them come out
and say they don't trust the 911
Commission report and I believe Vivek
ramaswamy is being honest I mean this in
any traditional sense any traditional
political consultant would be like what
did you just do you nuked your campaign
but Vegas telling you actually what he
thinks and he's and he's completely
correct let me let me read this
political reports the fake ramaswamy
cast doubt on the veracity of the
government's explanation for the 9 11
attacks saying he didn't believe the
findings of the 911 Commission
he said quote I don't believe the
government has told us the truth I'm
driven by evidence and data what I've
seen in the last several years is we
have to be skeptical of what the
government does tell us I haven't seen
evidence of the contrary but do I
believe everything the government told
us about it absolutely not do I believe
the 911 Commission absolutely not I am
tremendously impressed from this they're
they're trying to now claim he's like a
911 truther or it's like the underlying
argument no no no no no no that's total
BS if you believe everything the
government tells you you haven't read a
history book not a single one and I got
a bridge to sell you all he's saying is
something simple and I've said something
similar
why would any reasonable person think
the government issued a book explaining
one of the greatest security failures in
the history of this country they
wouldn't they would put out something
which is somewhat true but probably
there's a bunch of gaps in it because
they don't want to reveal Secrets as to
how we got attacked because we don't
want it to happen again Vivek is correct
you know that can be there's some
Community with a bit that's like uh you
don't need to believe in all conspiracy
theories but you don't believe in any
you think the government's just adding a
thousands we're like we talked about
like parenting and lying to his own kid
it's great I wish I could remember oh
that's a good one yeah uh we're like one
we're like one Biden mishap away from
finding out that aliens did 9 11 anyways
everyone be like okay
okay I mean if I guess I
I feel like I have to point out it's
like Vivek is
can is establishing the narrative like I
don't know the context in which this
came up it was being interviewed and
someone asked him explicitly do you
believe in this or if he just brought it
up on his own in his own interview which
I wouldn't put past him uh I I think
it's interesting that so often
especially on the campaign Trail you get
these guys who are like something's
happening at the border wall and I'm
gonna comment on it oh something
happened over here and all coming out
whereas Vivek is like I want to talk
about this now I'm going to give you my
opinion like that's like a that's a very
bold how does it even come up that
they're like do you believe 911. he's
like no if he had been on this show like
it would have been any one of you guys
to be like so let me ask you a question
here right for sure but like Ian it
didn't happen on our show so I feel like
I don't understand can I I just want to
play a quick snippet from The Whitest
Kids you know this is a 14 year old skit
and uh I only want to play a little tiny
bit of it
for waiting the president has asked me
to come out and make a brief statement
about the wire that just went out a
couple minutes ago
to make things short I will just confirm
that yes we do have a moon base and yes
we are currently experiencing some bear
problems now I will open it up if there
are any questions
uh yes I have a 10 no 11 part question
I'm sorry I only have time for two all
right let me get this straight so the
United States government is admitting
that we do have a moon base and that
there is a bear problem on said moon
base yes that is correct all right
follow-up question
are you with us
no we are not and I would like to remind
everyone to keep the language civilized
this is the White House so he basically
then goes on to say he says stuff like
yes well the Bear's been a bit ongoing
problem since the Wizards were attacking
and then they're like Wizards and then
uh let me let me jump right there's a
picture of the bear on the moon let me
let me jump to the end here and give you
the punchline Cycles we believe they may
be of the uh just a thought more of a
shot in the dark but uh
we wouldn't happen to be invading Iran
today would we
foreign
you got me
I fell for it I fell for it yes exactly
summed up perfectly 14 years ago by The
Whitest Kids you know it's so great
because we're experiencing it now we
have this we're like oh my God look at
Vivek questioning the not 911 uh the
specific narrative that the government
gave out he's questioning it in the
slightest but guess what guys aliens
like I said the government's out here
batting a thousand they just get it
right every time I mean that that seems
so ridiculous that they would be upset
that he's questioning something also I
feel like the implication from this
article is like he's denying 911 right
to be like are you crazy that's not
what's happening at all wouldn't it be
funny if there's like an alien spaceship
in orbit around Earth and they beam Joe
Biden up there and they're just like
what have you done why are you revealing
our presence and he's like come on man
they're gonna arrest me what am I
supposed to do got to do got to throw
them something to get him off my back
even he's like the least loyal person on
Earth or in outer space the UFO though
thing is a rabbit hole that's crazy I've
dug into a tiny bit if you look into the
past there were legitimate fed UPS where
they were creating disinformation
without within UFO research communities
and the reasoning was like I know it
sounds kooky but it's because a lot of
times they were actually sort of digging
into like secret stuff they're doing and
so then they take some UFO truth and be
like guess what dude I'm in the
government and I have some special
information for you let me tell you
about the terrarians from Saturn 25 uh
and then like this stuff just goes wild
and then so like I don't know for me
like I've been digging it a little bit
throughout this like the whole UFO stuff
and it's just like there's you can't
trust anything when it comes to the
government and Aliens like who knows
maybe they are real but I personally I
completely default the opposite way so
and what would like what would the
benefit be right now for them to reveal
it like we've talked about obviously
distraction from other stuff that's
going on but if the aliens are real what
does the government get from telling you
I feel like I just don't understand that
you'll listen to them because they
scared you with something else that was
just when they plan to release that
information it just so happens
some type of Scandal is coming not
non-human biologics have been recovered
now you must listen to us more I mean
stop questioning us you've put your
sciop hat on though like as ridiculous
as it is alien's super easy to pull off
like you just have somebody come come
out leak some information like so you
don't actually have to have an event
that really occurs you could have an
event but it's like oh we you could make
up an event that happened a decade ago
you could just take 10 000 drones like
what what what's the the mavic Drone
they do those light shows and they can
have a ship appear in in in the sky they
can just fake it you know and then be
like oh what was that they'll do in a
remote area everyone will film and
they're like it was for your own good
nobody nobody even cares at this point I
wonder you know they've they've tried
pushing the UFO thing so many times that
nobody cares anymore at all to the point
where when they came out and said
non-human biologics are recovered
everyone's like shut up dude yeah even
the UFO truthers are like no shut up
well they're like it's too expensive
here we go these these things are for
when we have luxury and freedom and
extra cash you have made it so we can't
enjoy these crazy things because it's
not fun to be here right now is anyone
extremely challenging to live under
these conditions does anyone really
believe that Donald Trump would have
kept his mouth shut if there were aliens
secretly in control of things and even
at this point with everything they're
doing he would just come out and be like
I'm gonna tell you all because they're
trying to put me in jail aliens are real
and you just come out say it and then
they'd be like oh no he's unveiling us
but he won't he doesn't because it's not
true they're just lying I mean to be
fair they probably would never tell them
about the aliens if they were aliens but
uh right yeah maybe that's the issue
maybe do you have you guys seen that
viral video where it's uh that old guy I
think it's like a foreman can former
Canadian Prime Minister or something
saying that aliens are real or something
like that and that they're telling us we
have to reduce carbon and reduce the
population and climate change wow
exactly what the elites are that weird
you know but that's exactly the point
right exactly they want it because the
aliens told them they have to do it also
why would we listen to the aliens that
seems crazy to me that was the plot of
the of the Independence Day movie
anyways that the aliens were here to to
suck up our natural resources but I
guess if all the natural resources are
gone then it doesn't matter they'll just
pass Us by so if we get rid of our
natural resources we'll prevent Alien
Invasion exactly
exactly yeah what the heck this is the
best idea of all time fracking in
America now it saves us
intergalactically yes why should I care
about the aliens like what's what what
is it right are they going to offer us
immortality or something or like
interdimensional travel or whatnot
because like I gotta tell you
the happiness is relative we all live
our lives we have our goals we have our
passions we're living them when we reach
the point of interstellar travel I'm
sure it'll become a passion project for
many people Elon Musk certainly uh is
very passionate about space travel but
what do we need from Aliens not serious
question has like when people had no
refrigerators they got by and they were
happy and then there was you know there
were problems and challenges but what is
what is it is the aliens are going to
come to Earth and give us future
technology and make us all Immortal or
make the elites Immortals they got to do
as they're told that's what I don't
understand like are we supposed to be
excited and wanting there to be aliens
or are we supposed to be afraid of them
because if it's we're supposed to fear
them then I understand why the
government is like yup they're here
listen to us the only people who know
about them because that's just asking
for compliance and if it's like the
aliens have something positive to offer
us I understand why the government would
keep it a secret because they're you
know the Arbiter of all good things like
I just don't understand where they fit
into anything that's relevant to my life
yeah it's also a big letdown for all the
like the hard line UFO conspiracy
theorists who've been waiting for that
confirmation for decades right because
they've been waiting for them there was
an interview with Dean hagland he was a
he was one of the actors in The X-Files
he talks about he's like the the sad
part about being a conspiracy theorist
is at the end of the day even if you're
right all you get to say is I told you
so they don't even get that now like now
they're just stuck with like now they
tell them they're real they're like
first of all I can't trust you whether
they're real or not and it's kind of a
letdown because gas is 9 gazillion
dollars a gallon and everything's
expensive yeah yeah also conspiracies I
just feel like you're totally right Tim
if if Trump knew about the aliens I
definitely think you would have told us
especially since he's the one who
relaunched space command I feel like he
would have been like I have good
evidence oh maybe that's why he did it
yeah maybe that's it okay so then why
would he want it to be in Alabama and
why would Biden want it to be in
Colorado that's just that's just that's
procedural bickering or do they like
walking to fight the aliens but that's
what I mean did Trump say they're
defeated by water you need to be close
to the Gulf Coast what if what if
there's that Colorado wait wait I figure
it out I figured out I know exactly I
know what's going on check it out check
it out
the aliens aren't here
they were here and they're coming back
and see the Democrats you know and and
the world economic Forum are like we
better get on our knees and do
everything the aliens expect otherwise
they're gonna be mad and Trump was like
no we're gonna build weapons and fight
back and they were like are you mad
they'll wipe us all out they're so
Advanced that's what's really return to
the lizard overlords that's right so
Earth is like Liz world's biggest Airbnb
and they're just coming back and we've
left it a mess and they're just pissed
about it well you know the conspiracy
about like Planet Eris or whatever right
I don't think conspiracy is the right
word for these things more like insane
ideas you know or like Fringe ideas
because like conspiracies like people
collude together to do a crime or
whatever but like one of these online uh
theories is that there's a a planet that
comes within uh close within our solar
system every 2500 years and so that yeah
Nibiru Planet acts
and that it's it's it's coming back and
the Millions who live on it genetically
engineered humans to be like a slave
race or whatever to mine gold and stuff
like that it's a fun Theory and someone
comes back they just like scoop up some
people no no they come here and then
they take out the gold and then they use
the gold to uh maintain their atmosphere
or something I love it at an all-time
high right now it's great it goes
somewhere down so many rabbit holes
that's where Nephilim like there's you
can connect it's an ethylm and all sorts
of stuff it's a fun one genies and
shaman on my show and we were legit
we're talking about Nibiru and how it
connects the feeling it was a fun time
it was wild but it was something
yeah I feel like that's not bad then
like we can just trade them gold I mean
I guess they like enslaved Us in this
this Theory I'm not sure as long as we
keep the silver I'm okay with it it
would just be you know more fun if that
stuff was true and I think people want
that stuff to be true because the
reality is life is mundane you know I
tweeted this earlier like how is it
people always say like how did it get so
bad in insert country and it's like it
never really did and what I mean by that
is every day something small happened
that no one thought was a big deal and
then finally crazy stuff was going down
that people thought was normal to the
outside world when they write the
history book and condense it all we're
like how did they go from this to this
it's like no one noticed but even now
people don't even notice crazy stuff's
happening now and they just don't pay
attention their their algorithms they
look at every day are pointing them in a
different direction so they're kind of
oblivious to the fact that a lot of this
craziness stuff this crazy stuff is
going on that's why I think Trump's
trial is so confusing to so many people
because it seems like they're just going
after him and they like they keep asking
him to turnover documents and then turn
to come up with charges against him and
like this actually happens all of the
time it's just that we all know Trump
and we have this information so rather
than for me to have to explain like one
person in their story and unique things
and get everyone to understand it we can
all say oh yeah I remember Trump oh wow
this is happening becomes much more
relatable it's it's something that's
gone on for a long time we just are
suddenly realizing it let's come back
down to earth we got this story from the
daily mail this is big news Tucker
Carlson interviewed Devin Archer this
was surprising I can't believe he got
him Devin Archer tells Tucker Carlson
Joe knew he was on calls with Hunter's
business partners associate says Biden
brand was absolutely key to business
deals and reveals the thank you letter
the then VP sent him so this is it in
the interview let me let me play this
clip for you real quick from Tucker's uh
show there you go these are not business
guys this is the vice president of the
United States he's not allowed to be
working on businesses with foreign
governments while he's vice president I
don't think not that I know of
but here he is right amazing he knew
what he was doing Devin Archer confirms
Joe Biden knew what he was doing Joe
Biden was using his son as a proxy so
that he could run business deals while
vice president and aside from Devin
Archer's testimony to Congress he's now
on Tucker Carlson with a thank you
letter from the VP Biden said he never
talked to any of Hunter's Associates
there's a stupidest lie imaginable he
could have at least tried and said like
of course I know Hunter's Associates I
don't work with them but yeah how do I
not know my son's doing business with he
comes by for dinner yeah well that's
their business I'm in government they're
doing business no he said I never talk
to him at all and now the media is like
trying to Gaslight and what was that one
article said it's long been known that
Joe Biden was speaking with Hunter
Biden's business associates actually not
at all yeah I mean we found out recently
but here you go meanwhile Donald Trump
is being indicted for like the 8
millionth time and uh what is it like
Mark Rubio's had to tweet out we got
some strongly word strongly worded
letters yep finally until the end of the
day all the law is the cudgel and the
way they're the way our legal system is
with so many laws you all there's always
something that you can get someone for
and this is a perfect example of it you
have Trump that's doing all these silly
little things and maybe technically by
the letter of the law there's some law
somewhere that says they can't do X Y or
Z but then with someone who is clearly
not breaking there's not a will to
actually enforce it yeah it's even worse
because then like maybe it's the worst
thing that ever happened in the country
but at least Trump is a Russian spy is
kind of cool all this stuff is just
boring yeah you know Trump being a
Russian spy you're imagining you know
Trump's got like this weird Gadget kit
in his jacket and he like pulls out a
little tiny earpiece and he's like
Vladimir I'm in played by Dalton sitting
in the Oval Office we did it yeah go for
eagle Commander Dolph Lundgren can play
him in the movie from Rocky IV he's all
ripped Trump just super ripped and sing
at the Oval Office well just like the
the like the taxes that was like five
scandals ago and nobody remembers it
candles and nobody cares because it's
just like you said it's just a cudgel
that they use to get like Trump's taxes
oh yeah particularly right it's just a
cudgel that they use as a as a weapon
against him because the law is used in
an adversarial manner here I think it's
because like I said before they're just
trying to slow him down and I think
that's why the media is so freaked out
by The credibility of the allegations
against Hunter and and Joe uh the fact
that this guy can produce a thank you
letter is is kind of hilarious when
they're over here like we spent millions
of dollars on this investigation and we
think maybe these things happened I
think it was a text between Hunter Biden
Devin Archer where Devin is like why is
your family destroying my life and
trying to put me in prison I was like
why why is your dad's Administration in
the pointy he's trying to destroy my
life and Hunter's like this is the cost
of a free country or something like that
what it actually sounds like is you were
of you're no longer of use to these
people and now they're disposing of the
loose threads you got to clean up shop
you don't want people to find out what
was going on in Devin Archer Tony
bobulinski they've been able to come out
and provide evidence
into the criminal or Shady dealings of
the uh Biden family do you think Joe
ever looked at Devin our turn was like I
wish I could trade you for a hunter but
people already know what Hunter looks
like because that's really the biggest
loose end of the Biden family I mean
that guy is just leaving laptops
everywhere and children in his wakes you
know what I mean like this seems like
the biggest weekend but there's nothing
you can do about it so this is what the
Biden family has created for themselves
but most people are still like I said
they still have their mind made up we
covered a thing earlier today where like
Amber Heard remember Amber Heard like
last year she pooped on the bed but uh
like the thing where like she like lost
a brand deal with L'Oreal and they
showed all these letters from women who
still to this day talk about her like
she's the greatest thing that ever
happened to feminism and she helped me
realize how important it was if you
heard depending on where you get your
information from you just don't know and
you're just going to be tricked into
believing that this is a good guy so the
average person who doesn't pay attention
to the news cycle doesn't hear any of
this stuff that's going on with Joe
there's the actual clip of him saying I
made this as a quid pro quo quid pro quo
in Ukraine and nobody knows about it
nobody cares because the average person
isn't paying attention and that's who
they've weaponized the dumbing down of
America through corporate press yeah and
I I actually think teams I think it's
somewhat inverted I think people in this
country have been stupid for a long time
I should say ignorant uh because of mass
media you only got information from a
few sources and now with the internet
we're becoming more educated and
informed on what's happening but it's
targeted you're choosing where you're
giving your media from you or I or
everyone here may be privy to looking at
right and left wing media the average
person doesn't do that and we just
thought we didn't have that 20 years
exactly the average person just follows
CNN because whether we believe CNN or
not they think that they're getting
informed by somebody from there or MSNBC
but it's even more targeted than it used
to be the point is that 20 years ago CNN
was your only choice obviously there's
Fox CB CBS ABC but they all said the
exact same things for the most part now
you have the ability to have dissident
media I don't think the average like I
just I feel like the average person
still doesn't look at that as a value of
course I think that's what I'm saying is
we we assume now that they're lying to
us like no they've always been lying to
us we just have the ability to go online
and communicate with each other I think
part of it is politics are exports teams
I like some people feel to their core
that they are a capital r republican
they are a capital D Democrat and
nothing you say will convince them that
anyone on their team did anything wrong
I mean think about actual sports teams
we'll go get uh players who commit very
obvious and well-documented case of like
domestic violence and the team is like
oh yeah that was the worst anyways he's
gonna sit out a couple games and then
we'll bring him back like people aren't
saying I'm now renouncing this team
which is supporting you know some
terrible person who doesn't live in the
values that I support with Biden it's
very easy for people on in the
Democratic party say like why I'm a
Democrat I only want Democrats to win
right now my options are Joe Biden and
his crazy family or RFK Jr or Marianne
Williamson if she's still hanging out
and that's it and so they're going to
cling and defend Biden because they are
trapped right if you're back since well
you're going to stick with your team
same for Republicans there are
Republicans who will say you know I am
this kind of Republican and Trump can
never be and I this is how the
Republican Party should be like they
become completely obsessed with the team
they think they have to show loyalty to
even when the team lets them down
Kennedy Williams in 2024. oh my gosh
let's go I feel like those podcasts
would be amazing you got to think the
demographic of people who actually vote
is typically older too and so you were
mentioning the distant media point and
it's like I do feel like we're almost
experiencing like a rise in class
Consciousness but like with this new
distant Medias and stuff coming up but
let's be real typically the older
Generations aren't quite buying on to it
so this is gonna be a lagging Trend that
takes a while to come into place but um
oh no go ahead how polite I'll moderate
here I lost my train what were you gonna
say I was waiting for your question no
but now like not feel bad like the but
the but the Democrats are the ones
weaponizing influencers and the youth
because they want to get the youth vote
and they want to get people out in
voting more than they were before right
yeah like let's be real most of them
yeah and I feel like democrats for a
long time I've been like no no it
doesn't matter who you vote for we just
want you to vote but specifically here
are the candidates you should vote for I
mean there are things that you know the
Republican party and a lot of other
political parties that are out there
could have done meaning they could have
treated the get out the vote effort like
it was this you know Trojan hearse we're
just trying to talk to young people what
actually was obviously Democrats trying
to connect with youth voters uh I think
that's again why the Civic engagement
conversation that that vivekan Swami
brings up is really interesting because
I think people do especially now they
have access to Alternative forms of
media online feel called to do something
right if you get to hear all this awful
stuff all the time you can either
collapse and depression or act and I
think that's what people want and that's
why you know
the Democratic party is still pointing
fingers and they're becoming less
appealing
yes thank you thank you for your consent
sometimes I feel like I come to the show
and just like talk to myself in the
mirror for an hour which is like maybe
not the best
I don't know man
I'm just thinking about
2024 is around the corner and we are
lucky right now to be we here's what
we're doing we're all sitting on the
beach
Miami Beach in fancy chairs with
coconuts going all that Joe Biden you
hear about this and then off in the
distance there's the biggest hurricane
we've ever seen and it is coming
where we are right now is the chill time
with all the craziness they're doing
with the Devon Archer stuff with the
indictments against Trump that's just us
seeing lightning off in the distance
what's gonna happen next year we're
talking I mean dude we're talking five
or six months from now
so we're looking at about what eight
months no not even seven months until
the primary
Trump's first criminal trial is going to
be then
it is going to be wild Bonkers could you
imagine if it's not though like it's
just nothing happens and we're sitting
here and like nobody cares about
politics nobody's watching anymore and
they're just like oh we don't care
anymore and then just that's it Biden
wins again there's no one really talks
about it
it is funny how like I feel like in the
past used to be able to actually make
more accurate political predictions to
some extent but now we've gotten to the
point to where there are so many factors
and so many crazy things like just Trump
and Biden alone between the two of them
the two scandals going on there like
those are both insane scandals on their
own just like I mean in different ways
obviously but I don't know it's just
it's like trying to predict the future
or have an idea of what's going on like
I was just talking on the airport to
somebody today but then the airplane
today about like whether Biden will run
and I'm like I have no idea like I mean
it seems a silly idea to do so but the
same time we're getting so close do you
really not I I I don't know like how do
you get another four years of this guy
without actually making a clone I don't
know I think I I think there's a strong
possibility that in Biden's old age and
with his existing ailments something
happens to him
and I imagine what would be
for the Democrats the most beneficial
thing imaginable
would be if like Gavin Newsom is at a
Biden rally and talking about how he's
here to support Joe Biden and Joe
Biden's the greatest president and then
Biden suffers like some health ailment
or something he fell on stage that one
time maybe he has a stroke
well like you've tripped in the sandbags
but he's fallen upstairs but imagine the
scenario where Biden's is speaking at
some kind of Rally or whatever or just
on TV maybe because I can't really
muster up anybody to come to a Biden
rally Gavin Newsom is there I think it's
likely going to be him and then Biden
collapses Gavin runs to to save him all
on TV get a medic in here and then
there's this oh the news oh no oh Joe
Biden cue all the conservatives being
like we don't like the guy but we're
really sad about what happened to him
Gavin Newsom steps up and starts talking
about how you know this is a time for
leadership he's being interviewed by
everybody because he was there every
news Outlet sits him out sits him is
down and says like what was it like what
do you what do you think what now who's
gonna step up will you
and there you go deep state news of 2024
they're great ideas no I'm not taking
notes they're looking through their book
going like how did he get a copy of this
because he's halfway there
how do you get a cop but I'm but I'm
imagining so we're talking about if
Donald Trump didn't call the police like
it didn't order the police shut down the
the 529 Insurrection and let antifa just
run rampant he'd be president because
the narrative would be inverted and you
know I you know Michael Mouse is saying
ah the media would still lie about him
but I'm like yeah but they wouldn't have
the j6 narrative they would have the
extremism of the far left and regular
Americans would be asking why this
happened yeah I'm trying to think about
let's think forward in that context like
what could the Democrats do what could
Trump do to guarantee a victory and
obviously Joe Biden is not the guy
Trump's already beating him in a whole
bunch of polls he's a tying with or
beating him and so everyone speculated
that Joe Biden won't be the guy but how
do you get Joe Biden out if he bows out
it's it's weakness in the Democratic
party it's got to be something that can
pass the torch if Joe Biden went on
stage and said you know I'm just too old
so Gavin do some ladies and gentlemen
nah would never fly but if there's a
hero moment for Gavin where he steps in
to try and save Biden that gives him
every ER opportunity in the book yeah
especially because they don't want him
to pick another white man over Kamala
Harris because there was a time when I
think the Democratic party really wanted
her to be the obvious choice they were
hoping Biden would be a one-term
president and that she would ask the
vice president be the next one to
represent the party because she's
diverse and a lady and you know whatever
else important so they have to find a
way to make it so that Gavin you know
gracefully as a hero becomes the obvious
one it's not that she's being overlooked
it's that he just happened to be in this
you know what's the justification for
Gavin being in the Press 24 7 and live
to an election because he was there and
they're gonna say
Gavin you are heroically on camera seen
rushing to the aid of Joe
what was that like what was going
through your head he'll be like his last
words to me were yup you gotta take the
helm something like that I don't even
know if people would buy it anymore no
he's gonna say he's gonna say you know
tell Jill I love her and take care of my
kids and then Gavin's gonna start crying
and he's gonna be like you got it man
and he's gonna clench his hand and then
they're gonna be like wow Gavin Newsom
take care of my six I mean seven
grandkids
that statement made me brutal crazy I
know I wasn't on the show on Friday when
that came out but I was the fact the
arrogance of these people to be like we
care about all of our grandchildren
including Navy who we just happened to
learn about 30 seconds ago like where
have you been this whole time this is
what I mean by like how can anyone look
at the Biden family and be like four
more years this is going so well I think
the average person just doesn't know any
of this I really do I really do think
that they don't know that his family
life is this screwed up they don't even
know about the diary they don't know
about the laptop why the Navy statement
came out in people and magazine they
didn't say it to the New York Times They
said it to People magazine because
they're trying to present themselves as
like a let us get out in front of this
luckily People magazine all kinds of
have already covered the fact that this
you know super great guy hunter just
ditched his other kid and doesn't want
to use last name like I just don't
understand this family and their appeal
so unless the Democrat my only counter
to the the Gavin Newsom rushing to uh
Joe Biden's Aid story would be like if
the Democratic party starts to turn
tables and be like we had no idea that
he was working on these deals and this
is this is dishonor to us I don't know
that they could execute it perfectly I
don't think so then because guys it's
collateral damage yeah then what he does
is he's Joe is finally going to sniff
one kid too many and Gavin heroically
steps
gets one of Gavin's yes and then in
Joe at an event goes to sniff a kid and
Gavin heroically steps in between making
Joe accidentally sniff Gavin triggering
the stroke
interesting amazing
really that's the hero narrative they
need from him like we didn't know Joe
was doing any of this it's weird his
schedule and see when he and Gavin
Newsom are appearing on stage together
and we all need to brace ourselves to
get Joe Biden out of this it needs to be
a heroic Retreat it could theoretically
be something like he has a health scare
and then has to publicly announce that
he's done everything he can but as you
know this is a tough job and it's been
very taxing about the young man I used
to be that's a light possibility or
terminal he'd have to be like I actually
only have six months and then and then
he looks at the camera and says America
I ask you for one thing with my final
statement to you
vote Democrat man we're gonna we're
gonna fix it don't let these Fashions or
something like that yeah headed to the
big ice cream shop up in the sky you're
right you're still right that like they
would need to really find a a big way of
introducing Gavin Newsom over Kamala
Harris because I think if the Biden
administration of Democrat Party turned
the Kamala Harris they're going to
isolate a lot of Voters but with numbers
like that who who even wants I'm not
saying she's popular I'm just saying
there are a lot of people who feel like
the Democratic party needs to be led by
a woman who is of color and to turn it
over to another white man would be bad
if they if they can't run Kamala Kamal
doesn't have the support but they will
be
she doesn't have the
who is of higher mental status I thought
there was no more Michelle Michelle
Obama I thought that was gonna be a
thing so my so my understanding is that
they do want to run Michelle but
Michelle doesn't want to run I don't
blame her yeah I mean it's it's like the
most relatable thing I've ever heard of
him who wants to run like seriously who
would I can't even believe Vivek wants
to run it's like y'all are crazy
especially given that like Obama's
they're I mean they're very wealthy now
they don't need to just they own like
three production companies in Italy
she's having a great time yeah can you
imagine the stress can you imagine the
campaigns against her especially the
memes all the Big Mike stuff and all
that stuff it'd be I don't know it'd be
I mean I'd love it it'd be fun to watch
but uh also like Hillary Clinton held
office before she ran like Michelle
Obama was the first lady and then was
like yeah and we're in it would be such
a
cringy diversity point like I don't know
I wouldn't want to be there what are
your credentials I slept with the
previous president
oh that you know hey school lunch
program stuff yeah she wanted kids to
lose weight I guess but that's not
that's not good in today's day and age
you can't say that now
to rewind a little bit back to the point
I was making about you know we're
sitting on the beach looking at the
storm off in the distance we know the
storm's coming
so what do we do now right what are what
are what what do we do to prevent the
worst elements of the storm if anything
could be done right I'm not I'm not sure
humans have the ability to fight a
hurricane off so I think the reality is
going to be
don't like
get ready in a matter of speaking
meaning like do you know where the eggs
are in your house you know uh uh do you
have somewhere to go in the event of
mass unrest in cities because that's
extremely likely
I think we're gonna see a ton of writing
throughout the summer but I could be
wrong who knows I think there's a decent
possibility that like nothing happens
yeah and we're just like wow nothing
happened there's a lot of political
bickering in the news like we're seeing
now but I I really feel like
when Trump
his trials are coming up
he's going to be in multiple criminal
trials the news is going to be the
craziest you've ever heard
CNN is going to be salivating they're
already salivating the idea of covering
what are we on four three I think but
the with with Fulton County yeah yeah I
mean with Fulton County so you've got
New York classified documents 2020 and
Fulton County you're gonna have four
different criminal proceedings all going
on around the exact same time
maybe what actually happens is that
people just turn the TV off figuratively
I mean like I can't track all these
criminal proceedings I'm done maybe
that's what they want to happen this is
a good point yeah what's the point right
they want people to say he's guilty by
sheer volume of things that he said they
don't have the opposite effect I think
it's for some people it'll have it'll be
too much noise like how could he
possibly be guilty of all of these
things all of these Trials happen to
happen at once like you can't take it
all in so you start to say like I just
don't believe you and I don't want to
have this conversation anymore or I
don't want to watch any more of this
I've seen both on YouTube comments just
today I said someone one person is
saying like well if my I don't want
someone that's been indicted like why
would I want to like someone that's been
indicted for anything the other person
was saying he's been indicted for four
different things like there's no way
that he's been indicted for all there's
no way he did all these things how would
he have the time to do that and and do
all this there's just no way possible so
it goes both ways everyone who's gonna
win out a lot of people would take the
where there's smoke there's fire yes
well why why would they lie why would
they lie about that and they'll just
assume that well if four different
jurisdictions all came to this
conclusion of their own accord mind you
there is no backroom dealings at all I'm
sure uh that he must be guilty there
must be Republicans attorneys yeah there
must be no Republican prosecutors
anywhere right they're all like you know
what I'm gonna do we're in West Virginia
I'm gonna go to like find a local
prosecutor's office and I'm asking why
he's a Democrat
and then well I'm not I'd be like come
on if you're if you were actually a
republican you'd be criminally charging
these people right the the the the
Hillary Clinton stuff took place in West
Virginia they ran elections Nationwide
her name was on the ballot right so when
she tried to defraud the the country and
the the fraud led to a massive 30 plus
million dollar investigation as to
whether Trump was secretly working for
the Soviet Union how come there's no
there's no criminal charges for that
because the Republicans are timid and
Democrats Play for Keeps yeah I think
it's because Republicans are Democrats
and they're just pretending they're not
they're going the speed limit but but
it's but but that's the saying but I'm
like no actually they're probably Kevin
McCarthy has gone behind the scenes and
high-fiving you the party right yeah
we're talking about Trump here so it's
not really so much a left or it's right
thing as there's establishment versus I
guess you could say dissident it would
be a good way to describe the other
energy and I think Tim's right I think
there will be people checking out but I
think that will be more the right to
some extent roughly the people that are
in the know because they know like this
is nonsense you're just throwing a bunch
of stuff at it it's just static at this
point but I think that on the flip side
the left we may see especially if he
inevitably probably gets off or if he
does get elected they'll be screeching
the streets all over again we'll see all
that nonsense again but I think the
right's gonna start retreating locally
like the the people of the right like
the the voter base they're gonna start
retreating embracing localism and and
honestly that's kind of the better way
to go yeah I think this is sort of an
answer to your question of like if we're
on the beach right now and we know the
storm is coming when do we decide to
leave the the beach and go make sure our
homes okay like I would like to see you
know we might not be able to stop
whatever crazy fighting is about to
happen on the federal level but it would
be interesting to see people say like
well how do I protect myself at home how
do I insulate it who runs their school
board who runs your school board who
runs your elections who's running your
town what what decisions are they making
because again in some ways the worst
part about all of this is that it's a
big distraction from the the tiny
decision what feel feels like Chinese
but they're actually massive in your own
life right they make all the different
personal relationships that people live
around you the decisions for for zoning
or anything else that happens locally to
you that stuff is way more likely to
affect you on a daily basis than any of
the large-scale national politics yeah
so to Tim's Point like it's it's that we
have to decide it's time to leave the
beach and go make sure our homes are
okay I don't know if I agree with that
um I certainly agree that local politics
are extremely important but it's it's
probably a balance of sorts I mean the
stuff we saw with the federal government
ESG woke policies the Department of
Education the curriculum stuff they push
you've got like the complaints over
Common Core whichever several years ago
now you've got the schools pushing all
this you know gratuitous content all
this comes at the federal level sure but
the only way to stop it coming down from
their level is have
both I think right and so I'm saying
it's not that you can ignore the federal
election I'm just saying like it would
be good to not get so lost on if or
Trump did this or whatever that you
don't know who's running in your own I
just feel like to some extent the
federal move is almost a lost cause
maybe not but I think there is something
for example one thing I liked about
DeSantis is he was making moves within
his state where it was kind of in a
sense distancing himself somewhat from
the federal government and doing his own
thing uh kind of almost a soft
nullification soft session to some with
and I personally would like to see that
energy continue to go forward and start
separating yourself further where you
can so that federal government has less
effect on your life so we just start
ignoring Democrats and whenever they
talk we just go I can't hear you I can't
hear you nope nope no one's someone
there is someone talking I have no idea
let's talk about something completely uh
irreverent irrelevant but uh you know
let's lighten the mood a little bit
so this is a big story former lizzo
dancers were weight shamed and pressured
while at strip club lawsuit says I like
how it says pressured while at strip
club uh not for the the kids I will say
but uh we'll we'll keep the uh overt
language to a minimum and um my
understanding is that they were actually
physically abused
yeah at these clubs they were they were
pressured into doing things and I I
don't know if we can say that on air
here but uh bananas were put places
bananas aren't supposed to go and then
they were told to eat them from the
places oh no don't blame me I'm just the
messenger here uh okay but here's I do
blame you it's the pop culture house
yeah here's here's the important part of
the story as to why we're talking about
it because lizzo was weight shaming yes
dancers
lizzo is morbidly obese there can only
be one
okay this is my question is she saying
like you're too heavy or is she saying
you're not heavy enough oh that's a
great question
oh
if you really want to be in my tour
you'll eat all of the donuts like no one
has said it explicitly I don't
understand I spent about 20 minutes
talking about the day so I'm about over
this whole discussion I'll be completely
fair but it's uh I mean that's not the
worst there's really funny like mixed
messages where she's got like a lady who
works on the tour with her who's like
very religious but also like simulating
sex acts in front of people it's the
weirdest it almost feels fake the how
how over the top the story is but it's
it's gonna cost her I'll be honest I
don't really care about the inner
politics of lizzo but the issue I see is
the biggest culturally the culturally we
have this body positivity thing they say
lizzo is beautiful but then inside this
you know this company whatever they're
telling these these people they're too
fat
so it's it's something like what is this
how does this how do these things
coexist yeah I also think this like the
point that they're saying like they're
at a strip club going to strip clubs is
like all of the uh women I know who
proposed to be sex positive feminists
are like going to a strip club is
empowering and it's good and you should
go so it's this Clash of cultures where
it's like if you don't go then you are
not sex positive enough that's literally
and also when you go you're forced to do
things you're uncomfortable with and
maybe lizzo fat change or perhaps she's
skinny shames you it's unclear this is
one of those things I don't think
they're talking about like well the
answers yeah but were they overweight
enough I don't know you need to put on a
hundred pounds I'm just saying she
doesn't dance it's like the stories of
like Brides who get their bridesmaids
ugly bridesmaids dresses so that they
look better by comparison
I just want to know what direction this
was happening his name is Melissa yes
that changes everything she's um these
are the people that push a very very
toxically positive message meaning like
that that you have to feign positivity
at all times which is not how the real
world works and as you learn invariably
like I said earlier anybody who puts be
kind in a profile is the meanest person
you've ever met in your entire life it's
the same in these industries the harder
The Virtue signal the worse they are as
a boss as an employer as a general human
being and if you read more of the story
later said I'm going to spare everyone
the deals it's no no no I I got a
question about this I'm not going to
read it and I'm Gonna Keep the language
as as vague as I can
but NBC news says okay no don't pull
this up stick it out all right all right
NBC news says cast members took turns
catching objects launched from certain
areas of the body yes how do you
launched those things ask the people at
this at this strip club just so fun
company activity the best part about it
is there's like an interview with her
from like two years before this happened
where she talks about how she always
wanted to go to this one strip club and
that this was because this is the red
light district in Amsterdam right so
she's like basically he's almost like I
love bananas I want to go there to this
strip club and now it's coming back to
bite her because she's nuts
so why I'm sorry you're all men I don't
know perhaps you understand something I
don't know but this no this is also one
of those this is one of those things
where like look they were basically
shamed into doing this they're like well
if you don't come with you like you
don't have to but we'll judge you if you
it would be like Tim saying like hey
Brett you want to go skating on Saturday
I mean you don't have to come but you
know you might not have a job on Monday
if you don't come with me that's
literally what it is or for the rest of
the tour we'll just treat you like
you're exactly well they said like she
would do other concerts that were not
part of the tour and the only the people
who like hung out with her outside at
these events were the ones who got those
jobs so it's basically just like do you
remember when oh no okay so recently
Robert Downey Jr had a thing where he
talked about how after making
Oppenheimer said women should run the
world in in Oppenheimer yeah they said
women she's like what this movie taught
me is that women should run the world
because they have a better way of
handling problems this is the exact
proof to the opposite of that that I
don't know if it would be better but or
if it would be worse but it's certainly
not going to be any better don't like
being a bad boss is not gendered doesn't
like every military-industrial complex
Corporation have like a female CEO or
something not all right now but yeah
like a couple years ago yeah like women
should run run the world and it's like
there's a bunch of women that are
blowing up kids Boeing is like yeah
let's do that both men and women are
equally bad and good at resolving
problems but I do not think women should
exclusively around the world it's like
when people say like there should be an
all women's Supreme Court like what are
you talking about that's a terrible idea
Barbie movies look no no the men and
women are different right men are object
oriented women are subject oriented so
what happens is when you've got like a
Hillary Clinton and like a Barack Obama
Obama sees a map and on the map he sees
a military base and he says I think we
should uh bought that military base and
then like oh let's get let's confer with
Hillary what she thinks and Hillary says
we should blow up those people yeah so
you see what I'm saying like Obama is
targeting some object of some Merit and
Hillary is like I hate them blow them up
so you say women are evils
more people at least she's being honest
about what's going to happen the uh but
the what it is it really is it shows it
shines a light on the toxic positivity
that this is what Hollywood and all
these industries push is like it's an
unrealistic expectation of how human
beings interact and invariably just like
men behind the scenes uh a bad you know
a bad tour manager a bad boss a bad
celebrity is not is not restricted to
one gender or one type of person but
very often it is true that the people
who feign the most kind of heart who
pretend to be the most good of heart or
good of virtue end up being the worst
type of people and I don't think that
has anything to do with a weight to
sexuality or a gender yeah you did bring
up a good point before we started this
was the essentially a inverse of the
casting couch and in multiple ways I
think but it is it is funny how that
literally is the casting couch situation
but in a different setting and so in
this setting maybe the illusion is
supposed to be somewhat okay I actually
don't even know it should be necessarily
legal but she should be shamed like
she's being I just wanted amazing I want
to give a shout out to the Babylon B for
like the best response to this with an
article they titled three dancers Sue
lizzo alleging she ate them and their
entire family
Joey B tune Joey B toon said good luck
to convincing that judge that the that
lizzo shared food
um yeah it's just it is it is just a
microcosm of just how awesome it's okay
to make fun of her though because she's
apparently some kind of rapist so you
know she's you know she's a very bad
person the the rest of the stories the
stuff with the the assist the manager
who is also making everyone
uncomfortable and the threats to
people's job keeping people working for
like 12 hours at a time after a concert
and saying you're gonna lose your job if
you don't do that a lady who worked for
her
urinated on herself because she was
afraid to go backstage and go to the
bathroom because she felt she'd lose her
job that's the type of thing you'd hear
of a guy that a guy would be the one
who's such a hard boss that I felt like
I couldn't leave otherwise I would end
up having to female bosses are just as
whack as mailboxes I don't know what to
tell you well you and I know that the
average population these days this is
almost worse because it's like emotional
manipulation but my favorite is uh the
data showing that men and women equally
don't hire women at the same rates so
these women are like women should be in
charge and then things would change and
it's like the women who are in charge
like I'd rather have a guy do women
enforcement patriarchy there was also
there was also talk that there was
racialized elements to this like that
the the black dancers were treated
different than the dancers of color uh
they're no white dancers but dancers of
color no white dancers not racist though
no but but the point is that they're
saying that certain ones were treated
differently and it's all it all kind of
falls together it's like it's Hollywood
they deserve each other let them let
them fight wow you don't say it at big
girl touring yes I'm just yes you know
the body positivity thing is what I
first noticed from this story I mean the
stories like totally messed up like nine
articles it was like literally split
between like nine articles because of
all the stuff that came out about this
today I just think
how does lizzo get famous like do people
really like her music yes yeah yes she
had some like cool songs that I was
really she had one I think she has
insulin resistance I don't know anything
about her because that's the new single
I know that she released
um
trying to be funny I was being serious I
think I think she because she's on stage
and she's working like dancing so that's
the point she's talking about like the
other dancers can't keep up with her
because she's like actually in better
shape than them right and the reason she
doesn't lose weight is because she has
insulin resistance probably from like a
very poor American you know high sugar
diet anything I wish her the best
comes out with I have insulin resistance
it reminds me of like Kevin Costner
being like yes maybe stuff happened but
I'm choosing to live as a gay man and no
that was Kevin Spacey yeah I can't
remember any actor sure I was accused of
that but and if I did it's a drunken
Mistake by the way he got some news
about me he didn't get convicted in the
UK they let him off no but I mean the
the thing is like lizzo had some like um
I don't remember which one the one about
like being broken up with she wrote some
song and it was like not a hit and she
was like I'm gonna if if this isn't a
hit then I I don't know like she really
does understand pop music in a way it's
just that everything about her since
she's gotten famous has become like
about the body positive movement about
accepting the way I am about actually
praise me the way I am and I think
that's the problem like it's not like I
don't know like Adele used to be really
heavy and she sang Some Fun music and
she was a pop star and it was a good
time
she went all right I'm gonna write I'm
gonna write this song What kind of song
should it be should it be like a
acoustic folk or should cause influence
or is it called insulin resistance yes
yes acoustic folk like heartfelt and
like definitely definitely heartfelt
that's for sure
you know or maybe maybe punk rock
yeah that sounds like insulin resistance
doesn't feel like it could be like I
don't know I'm thinking dance disco yeah
you know I've been listening to some
disco recently because we were we were
listening to Boney M oh no it was Boney
M so good sweet maybe we should write a
disco song yeah let's see if we can get
like I wonder how much it costs to get
lizzo like it's like a feature on the I
don't think she's gonna be wanna be on
myself sure because I'm sure we could
try I don't think Liza's gonna want to
be on a song title lizzo has insulin
resistance
let's just be called insulin resistance
this is
called resistance so and it's and it's
not meant to be mean I'm gonna make it
very clear I am genuinely concerned
about the bad dieting habits of
Americans awareness and I also it's it's
a point to be critical of someone who
would would weight shame her own staff
while she herself is is currently
suffering from a a weight issue she's
also counting on you not being mean to
her because of because of herself I
still think she's she's shaming her her
dancer saying they're too skinny I mean
I think it's the other way right I mean
there's different types of fact she's
clearly like o-line healthy type fat you
know what I mean like can move you know
what I mean but that's the thing that's
why I said insular resistance that
wasn't it was making a joke like
people I was the one being you see these
videos where it's like people who are
very big are like moving really well
linebackers yeah yeah and there's videos
of skateboarders for instance you'll see
on Instagram where they're huge but
they'll be skating really well and I'm
just like this is somebody who's got I
don't know if it's insulin resistance
but some kind of like I don't know
thyroid problem or glandular issue that
their body isn't burning the fat but
they clearly are building muscle and
ability I see lizzo and I'm like this is
this is something about the garbage
plastic we eat in our food every day the
brominated flowers the phthalates the
pcbs all that stuff because the story I
hear over and over again I swear I ask
everybody this they say oh I was from
this country and when I came to America
I ate the exact same thing but I gained
30 pounds yeah and people say I I you
know when I went back to visit my family
for a few weeks I lost 10 pounds it was
crazy like something is wrong with our
food but let's jump to this next story
seemingly irreverent and irrelevant as
well ladies and gentlemen the US has
banned light bulbs nice so uh so how you
guys doing
I remember when I took AP environmental
science when I was in high school and
having to do a project where we have to
we went to our our middle school and
then convinced them that the swirly LED
whatever they are the better light bulbs
were in fact better and if we didn't do
that then you know we didn't get as good
a grade on the project and now I really
regret that because that was complete
propaganda paid for by college board Yep
this is kind of crazy though I mean the
the big story is they've banned
incandescent light bulbs you can only
now Buy LED light bulbs because they
last longer and use a lot less less
electricity it's kind of crazy I mean
how do they just ban something like that
isn't that an act of Congress they've
been phasing it in for years they've
been doing it for a while it's really
funny there's an episode of I I really
think it was the show Castle where they
catch a guy who works for like the city
transit authorities like they've been
phasing out incandescent to compact
fluorescent he's selling the
incandescence overseas and like the
whole like the idea is that it's
ridiculous and why would that happen but
that's obviously you know between that
and your gas stove and they said they
were going to do it and they made you so
excited it's about the environment and
now like I know tons of people who will
see the other light bulbs and be like
okay no big deal like LED lasts longer
it's better for the environment and like
perhaps that's true I just don't like it
when the government is like so we're
gonna introduce everything you want to
have an incandescent life
look at old videos like if you have like
VHS tapes or anything like if you have
like home videos where there's lights on
out in the streets when you were growing
up unless all those lights are orange
and now like you don't see orange light
anywhere outside but look look my point
is how does the bite Administration just
unilaterally decree that a certain
product can no longer be sold but it
wasn't the buy admission
Administration on Tuesday down to two
new rules that set stricter energy
efficient standards for light bulbs
those standards will phase out the sale
of most new incandescent bulbs but
they've been trying to phase out and get
us the balls for years I mean well
before right in Congress will need to
pass a law Banning incandescent light
bulbs so again Joe Biden can't just
decree it it's the shadowy forces from
Big bulb that have been lost should we
should we Sue because we want our
incandescent light bulbs yes I mean I'd
be like only Congress can do it this is
what I think is the the weirdest thing
about the bioministration which is they
were like we're for the environment and
therefore we can justify anything we
want by saying it's for the betterment
of the environment you know what this
means you got a new shirt is you got to
come and take it shirt with it oh that's
a good idea the light bulb with the
light bulb on it I honestly don't and
the gas shows at all you put the light
bulb above a gas stove I bet someone
made that on the pizza oven yeah exactly
did it say if it was through executive
order because I mean I'm wondering it
just says he adopted rules because
that's I believe the actual supposedly
like why what's supposed to be the
purpose of executive orders is to
probably kind of provide clarification
for existing things that are happening
of how this is how we're going to do it
so and they like she like I believe they
probably have been having legislation go
for forever so the pistol where I can
understand it the pistol price thing has
been rejected I believe judge States the
uh rule regulating pistol braces under
nfas is likely unconstitutional you
can't just keep Banning things like this
you can't just be like I hereby decree
so you know maybe we need to uh not
because I like incandescent light bulbs
actually I'm not a fan I like LED better
but uh it's it's the it's the principle
of the matter maybe maybe we should sue
the federal government and say you have
no authority to ban light bulbs in this
way protest put some incandescence up
here in the studio start manufacturing
our own incandescent so that we're not
selling them we're buying them we're
making our own yeah that's how you solve
these problems I guess the uh the the
the the the it's climate it's a climate
change agenda thing yeah but what I
think is that what it actually is is
um
you know you know what I think about the
security at airports why they make you
throw away your shampoo to sell more
shampoo yeah that makes sense because
they're they're like oh you you can't
bring that liquid in here because we
don't know what it is and then it's just
like you walk behind the security and
there's a whole bunch of really
dangerous chemicals for sale at like
these various news but they're in small
quantities so it's safer they tell you
like what if I bought more though
there's this dude named Evan booth and I
I went and met up with him he did his
project where he was able to make
various weapons combustibles and things
like that within uh not not in an
airport but with things found within an
airport so you cross security you go to
the store what can you buy I won't say
them now on the show but yes we were
able to make
um improvised grenades using things you
can buy in an airport so the fact that
that research had been done this is like
12 years ago and that we have not seen
substantial moves on this what I see is
the reason the government made these
rules is because they're like it's going
to increase sales at these uh locations
in the airports which will generate more
tax revenue for us
simply put when when it comes to light
bulbs they're just looking at like how
can we generate more economic flow a
major shift in the economy will force
people to adapt it will change houses
it'll change standards and this will
force people to buy things when I still
remember like the first time I flew
during covid and like all the signs to
like make sure to to wash your hands and
they were all like sponsored by Purell
at the airport and I'm just like well
that's creepy right like it's it's
literally like an advertisement for the
company but it's put through actual
official airport policy right it's an
actual form that's put up by the airport
but in the corner there you get the
little Purell paid for it yeah exactly
so it's it's kind of government and
business working through many people
even really use incandescent light bulbs
more because I was just thinking about
it just it's so typical of government to
where they get to this point to where
the the essentially the private Market
is essentially adapted and then they
come in with a rule like look look what
we did and it's like you didn't really
do it I just I don't I don't feel like I
see incandescent light bulbs all that
often and they do that with like R22 a
couple years ago because of the ozone
layer a couple decades like a couple
decades ago like it's starting to face
out yeah like HVAC people used it so
they they phased it out so there's like
a black market for R22 to use I mean
they did that with stuff like child
labor laws it basically people weren't
really working their kids by the time
they started instituting those laws
because we had progressed economically
to a point where people don't want their
kids to work generally speaking so I
mean don't be wrong I guess it's sort of
good that they stopped some of those
kids but I mean I I know it's just they
come the government comes in and then
later it's like look what we did and
you're like well I mean the kind of at
the last minute the taking credits for
it when they didn't really do any of the
work in 2007 Obama said that he was
gonna immediately send a law to phase
out all incandescent light bulbs and
that was reversed under Trump and so now
the volume Administration was like and
we're back just payback like that's
we're so back baby we're so back
why this is not also like if LEDs are
better
presumably the consumer is like I see
the results and I want one like why do
you have to ban them that seems bizarre
to me they're like Trump and your jail
cell will have nothing but LED light
bulbs no incandescent no romantic
lighting for you yeah
like what if that's actually why they've
been trying to stay in power for so long
this is like the one I'm telling you
it's the Inca it's the light bulb
conspiracy it's the P it's the forces of
big bulb oh my goodness so uh most what
does it say uh
someone uh Super Chat this is a good one
Kenneth Lauren sang are the bulbs made
in China or the USA so I just Googled it
and it says uh light bulbs made in the
USA do they exist it seems like they
don't since most consumers look to
purchase a cheaper bulb most light bulbs
are manufactured in China where it is
more cost effective so I think that's
just referring to
um incandescent light bulbs no I think
it's all of them all light bulbs are
made in China
can someone please let me know on
Twitter because I will only buy their
light bulbs like that's bananas Public
Square oh my gosh Public Square I need a
specific light bulb vendor
yes there is the light bulbs made in the
USA Patriot bull light bulbs made in the
USA
bulbs Trump is like we're going to be
launching light bulbs uh him in the
pillow guy can do that together yeah
that'd be good yeah I don't know that
that's a really good question though
because these moves could be made to
shift production and and revenue
generation and things like that but
place that really doesn't care about
child labor I don't really care about
light bulbs to be honest I'm just more
so concerned that we are now at a place
where the the the federal government has
just been ruling by decree just
mandating so on the surface it is but a
simple story about light bulbs that no
one cares about but when people ask how
did it get so bad
this is exactly it no one cares they
banned light bulbs No One's Gonna Go
protest over it but they do things like
this where they rule by decree a year
from now people will be like what do you
mean the government has always done this
sets the Precedence too that's right I
mean this is the moment where I want to
say like everyone I think you're right
it would be nice to Sue I don't know
that I personally have the cash reserves
to fight the federal government that can
litigate you to death but it would be
interesting if we had these I don't know
Representatives who we could call and be
like hey how did this come to be and I
don't like it please fight for my right
to have an incandescent light bulb if I
so choose let me guess so I don't know
where you'd find them maybe the House of
Representatives or the senate or
something but hey gas stove slapped
though so that's different because I
hate them right yeah they hate they hate
the gas stoves yeah they're illegal in
Vermont apparently gastos are
incandescent lamps incandescent light
bulbs yeah that's because
fluorescent light bulbs oh man I feel
like Vermont is such a wild Place
fluorescent bulbs are really cool
because you can like rub your feet in
the carpet and then like grab it lights
up like a lightsaber you know and then
taking away fun and the kids go and
shatter them in the in the alley and the
dust comes out and they all laugh then
it goes in their lungs and they get
really sick Vermont do you see what
you're doing what you're keeping us from
yeah yeah
well uh I suppose the story is like a
mix of climate change stuff and
government overreach or whatever but I
figured we'd keep it light now we're
gonna go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member because
the member's only uncensored show will
be at 10 pm and we will take your
questions live and I'm gonna be writing
a song about insulin resistance so uh
come hang out all right I'm not your
buddy guy says Jack Smith is a political
Hitman he should be disbarred and sent
to prison for life lots of the president
this abuse of power can cost your uh
cost you your life Behind Bars
can cost your life Behind Bars
can send you to prison
weird nug says Bud Light anyone LOL
who drinks Bud Light I've not actually
seen someone drink Bud Light in a minute
but we're in Maga country so I'm not
surprised is it still low are the are
the yes sails still down I saw a thing
that I read an article today that said
like some bars are like having to set it
up it's like it's a mystery logger just
to get rid of it like like they have to
put it on tap it's like it's a mystery
here we can't tell you what it is like
they had them all in a cooler and then
they had like blacked out this one shell
being like mystery it's funny my wife
just discovered the Bud Light
controversy yesterday and explained to
her and she was like yeah it is dumb
yeah so your wife is not into politics
no not at all that's amazing she just
found it yeah she just found out she's
my hero she's gonna get to Target next
and she's gonna be like did you know
I went to a Walmart and they were like
setting up displays more like Target
they're coming for Target it's so
interesting
all right let's grab some more we got
Raymond g Stanley Jr says I let anger
and emotions inside today guys I don't
like it this damn cycle of corrupt
government lying media both their
disdain for the lives of American people
wore needless death rinse and repeat
I completely agree and light bulbs and
light bulbs they're taking our light
bulbs from us it just never ends
I took our boobs it starts that's a dick
move taking our light bulbs I gotta be
completely honest I also hate those LED
light bulbs in the oncoming traffic it's
getting a little bit ridiculous well
it's like also really bright even in
here like I'm not a huge fan of like
that the bright light in here that's why
I don't wear my glasses in here like it
actually is like really hard in my eyes
so I can't even get an incandescent bulb
yeah save my life now well they're all
out yeah even the special lights that we
have they didn't even bother me till I
started noticing them all right
Aaron's Mickey says Tim went to see
sound of Freedom today and they said the
film was locked in the projector they
refunded me my tickets the conspiracy is
true yeah I've been here I've had so
many stories of it like people have been
coming just because we covered so much
of it like people with crazy stories
Beyond just like uh not just fire alarms
being pulled not just the air
conditioning not working and it's all
over the country it's not just like I
was very hesitant to buy that at first
because it's very easy to make that
claim and plus it's summer air
conditioning goes out places and you
don't have any comparison to like you
know regular and you don't hear the
stories like did this happen to other
movies because they're all on their own
AC systems right so it's like did this
happen to that's fine but did this
happen to the theater next to you yeah
but it's not it's I mean it's anecdotal
but I can only recall ever in my life
probably one time there was some sort of
technical issue with a film to where I
wasn't able to watch it or something
along those lines I was at uh Ford City
Mall when I was a little kid in south
side of Chicago and the power went out
and then everyone just started
ransacking everything I think my family
went to go see babe and then the power
shuts the power goes out and then we're
like walking to theater and everyone's
just running around stealing everything
in sight and then we just left they're
like get the Dipping Dots
yeah the Dippin Dots have been the ice
cream of the future for like 40 some
ideas seriously and no one's competed
with them that's the thing we did
actually have it probably when we went
to see The Flash the because we had to
go we went to a club we could only get a
closed caption screening and the closed
captions wouldn't work so they had to
like come in and like we're gonna refund
you your ticket they restarted the movie
like four times like like it get five
minutes in they're like okay the
subtitles aren't working so they have to
start it over again then finally like
we're gonna refund all your tickets and
then they let it they're like but if you
want to stay a complaint and then
immediately after they said that they
turned back on like that they
immediately turned on wouldn't it be
funny if like a mafia emerges to sell
incandescent light bulbs I can see what
I'm looking for it's a black market will
emerge yeah the Wild Wild West out there
light bulb prohibition won't work I'm
down
I just don't like that they're limit us
to one option right I feel like that's
not good I don't want single-payer
healthcare and I don't want single light
bulb choices I think we have a bunch of
we used to have a bunch of light bulbs
that were Wi-Fi
you can control them with your app or
whatever they didn't work though because
this place is too big and so we
installed like 40 because of how big it
is and this is like nothing worked and
we're like okay I gotta use regular
light bulbs bro do you think they'll let
us keep our light bulbs those are stupid
Healthcare job I have if you if you like
your bulbs you can keep your balls if
you do
let's grab some more Skyler Pearson says
you should try to get James Tour on he's
a professor of chemistry Material
Science and Nano engineering and
outspoken Christian bonus he knows about
graphene I think he would love him have
you guys heard about that thing it's
like LK 99 or whatever yes room
temperature superconductor it's not
really room temperature it's just like
closer to room temperature it's like
more feasible but until like it's been
proven by other places you know it's not
worth really covering people are saying
that if it's true that they've they've
generated this this you know near room
temperature superconductor we're gonna
have flying cars and stuff
yeah I mean it's possible and I'm just
like bro they told me graphene 20 years
ago was going to change everything Ian's
got the same little tube of graphene I
bought them like two two three years ago
for Christmas and it's been like nothing
okay actually to be fair they now put
graphene in uh batteries and they charge
super fast
so uh 10 years ago I'd buy these
Lithium-ion batteries everyone's got one
for your phone right and it would take
like an hour or two to charge up and
then it could charge your phone a couple
times now they have lifty uh they have
graphene I think graphene Polymer
batteries they're called what they do is
they take the lithium ion like normal
and then they lattice graphene over it
which allows the energy to flow through
it more evenly and it charges way faster
so we've got a couple of these portable
batteries it can charge it holds two
cell phone charges so about four
thousand milliamps it can charge in 10
minutes
crazy that's wild absolutely crazy so
okay fine Fair Point
I've also heard about solid state
batteries coming out yeah yeah I'm
waiting I'm waiting I want a flying car
with extremely dense battery I will say
I got the smart watch because Luke
recommended it
the battery lasts for a month wow that's
crazy I don't understand how it does it
yeah yeah it's a long time so how long
till flying cars then man
they've built flying cars a long time
ago the problem is that when like your
car breaks down on the road you just get
out and complain and when your car
breaks down in the sky you're dead yeah
we skip jet packs completely well but
but we have jet packs now you have that
you have those suits where they have the
things on their arms and they can fly
but we've had jet packs the problem is
the energy source was always difficult a
lot of gas so the the early jet packs I
think this was like decades ago could
only go for like 30 seconds now they
have jet packs that can go for about a
half an hour the problem is still when
they fail you die yeah that and those
they wear those suits you have to be
super fit to hold your arms because
you're you're basically doing like
like lift yourself with your arms and
hold that position for 30 minutes it's
gymnast stuff yeah yeah
but it is really cool because they're
using them to like do Mountain Rescue
they like fly up to the mountain stuff
that's pretty cool
you know and they also have those uh
they're like miniature plain suits
almost like it looks like a plane
standing upright but it's very small you
strap into it and then it you can you're
flying like like wing suit powered
wingsuit yeah and they're like really
big those are cool things too
Wyatt kaldenberg says VP Pence took
notes off Trump notes of trump Pence is
a system rat I would not be surprised if
Pence is the star witness for the state
I wouldn't either that I don't know why
he's running for president what a waste
of time yeah I don't understand how you
can run for president when the reason
people know you is because of trump like
yeah what was your game plan here team
yeah to waste everyone's time I guess
what do we got here Kevin cosnahan says
ironically having the trials is probably
better for Trump than actually
campaigning he seems to gain in the
polls with each indictment and that's
actually a really good point
these criminal trials are going to put
Trump on every television television
screen
every story everything will just be
Trump
maybe they're hoping people get sick of
it
we saw that played out last you know in
2016. maybe maybe they're they're trying
to do that so that people will be like
no I'm not gonna vote for the guy is
there uh are they letting cameras in the
courtroom so then we do we know that yet
we don't know I mean it's too far out I
think doing this so it like puts on
display the disingenuous I don't even
know how to say that disingenuousness
that's occurring so anyone who has an
ounce of Honesty will be like like if
anything it's going to be off-putting
like yeah maybe it might not help vote
wise but so far as like the actual
energy within the country the people can
be like yeah we know what you're about
and I think that's gonna cause it's
gonna shift some things in the future
yeah I think as well like we were
talking about how there's no covet
anymore there's not as much of like this
rallying cry against Trump anymore that
everyone has to do we haven't just had
any but who knows this summer could
change everything but a lot of I'm just
saying a lot of people that are on the
left ready for Biden are going to be
less like you know gung-ho about getting
out and voting so Spencer Jones says
let's get a giga Chad Ian t-shirt
yeah well okay it's gotta be no sleeves
then everyone sent us a video tearing
off their own sleeves yeah
so you buy it and you can rip your
sleeves
Noah Schram says Trump is made of rubber
you throw something at him and it
bounces off and hits you back but I
think the issue is just that the the the
the establishment doesn't understand
what people vote for Trump they don't
get it so they're like look he's a
naughty man and he Abused Women and
they're like uh-huh we hate you they
believe their own narrative about him so
it's hard for them to see him clearly or
objectively
Steven says says I was a classified
material control center clerk on Okinawa
with the Marines I had top secret
documents on National Security in my
control I can't tell you about them but
I didn't face any charges
well you're not Donald Trump and they're
not trying to remove you from office so
or from the from the race I thought that
was going to be an aliens comment what
if the real conspiracy is that Trump
actually is part of the deep State and
they're setting him up to be this
anti-establishment hero and that no one
thinks he can win and everyone keeps
saying he can't but then he will win and
everyone's gonna be like Yay but then it
turns out he does everything the Deep
State actually wanted
yeah like what if what if China is
pushing all the woke stuff and the Deep
state is actually desperately trying to
fight it because it's destroying America
and will result in US losing this global
conflict so they know the only way to
actually win is to prop up Trump as some
like Underdog anti-establishment guy but
he's actually deeply in and all on with
all of it and the point of the criminal
trials is to make sure everyone hears
nothing but Trump stuff so that he wins
40 chests yeah so so what you're saying
is yeah when he unbanned those
incandescent bulbs it was actually a
move all that time ago because they knew
they were going to reband him how much
do you want to bet
Donald Trump at Israeli says he's gonna
unban incandescent light bulbs and
they're all gonna go yeah
well he said it the first time he
already unbanned them once like he did
he's yeah yeah he was the one Obama said
we're gonna roll out Banning them Trump
was like no Biden was like yes and now
Trump's gonna be like you see you guys
need me they've taken our bugs
under me they're wearingcandescent balls
for everybody LEDs do bright makes me
look fat
no man
random Eskimo says I didn't vote in
2016. I was so disgusted we had no one
decent to vote for I saw how well Trump
governed and I appreciate his policy
while loathing his style I still
personally dislike him but he's earned
my vote you see so many people feel that
way yeah I'm just like the foreign
policy you know like even got some
Libertarians being like yeah I know like
no new Wars what are you gonna do if you
can't accept small victories that's what
I don't like about the Libertarians the
hardcore ones they're like Trump is bad
and did all these bad things and I'm
like I know but it's like it's actually
moved in a positive direction you can
call him the lesser of two evils I guess
but not starting any wars and working on
peace deals is good so complain about
everything else but like take what you
can I do think it's good to bring up
both though that like simultaneously
have these two concepts in your head at
the same time that we remind people hey
there's still work to be done uh like
you know just staying in the same
position we are while even somewhat
expanding forces in some areas not
really that but it's better than it was
before you know like we we didn't
increase our militarism as exponentially
as we were before so I mean I don't know
yeah yeah small wins I guess in some
ways but still you know there's work to
be done Joseph says Vivek is calling out
the investment Market that enough duh
follow the money I like Viva vague
Viva vague sounds dope I don't know the
nerdy beekeeper says calling Vivek the
right wing Obama insults Vivek
corollary it makes sense though yeah
yeah and in well yeah like Obama's evil
and the vague is good yeah you know so
there you go uh and E Knight says Vivek
has Jordan Peterson keeping him honest
it was a deal they made on Peterson's
podcast months ago it is really awesome
to see this meteoric rise of uh of Vivek
we had him on when we were in uh where
where was it Arizona that's right he
came on the show that was really cool he
had those books really excited to see I
I think it would be great if he was VP
that'd be really really awesome and
considering the the the the the serious
defense he's had for Donald Trump over
all this BS I think a strong possibility
because he's showing himself to be
worthy of running proving himself as a
capable order speaker uh you know he's
got good policies he's honest he's got
integrity and he's also
defending Trump where Trump rightly
should be defended something Ron
DeSantis should have done and given like
Trump's policies and the way that his
base sees him he would be a much more
realistic successor if Trump was to win
like if the idea was that Pence was
supposed to to be the one to to succeed
him after Trump won a second term I
don't think anyone was buying that
people would buy the fake winning after
after Trump they said he will not work
for vice president that he's running for
president yeah
he said that I loved it because he was
like some people are just not wired that
way can you imagine a vice president
Trump it's like very hard very difficult
KB says Tim pipe dream but what you guys
think about the scenario where Trump
eats at a popular vote win and the
Electoral compact States Auto trip to
Red everyone on our side must vote this
time since the D's made it matter now
but the Electoral uh compact is not in
play it has not been activated
still we definitely want every single
person to vote yeah so shift those
numbers man
Aleister Busan says YouTube won't let me
say what I want to Super Chat even
though it's verifiably within their
rules so here's 20 bucks for doing an
excellent job well thank you very much
Kai L says 561 is the Palm Beach area
code is that what Trump was equally
doing
Gary says it's Vivek like cake why is it
so hard LOL dude and we've had people on
the show who will say Vivek 20 times and
will say it's Vivek and they'll go oh
okay but Vivek is really great and we're
just like well it feels right let's save
it back but I've heard of fake a million
times as well it's also really hard to
like do a show where someone says Vivek
and then we stop the conversation and go
it's pronounced Vivek yeah I really feel
like he probably doesn't even really
care he doesn't he just introduced
himself he's like it's vague like cake
oh okay and it's like what people call
me whatever yeah you know people call me
Tom I just be like okay where it goes
whatever makes you happy I suppose
whatever makes you happy
this woman says does your state owe you
money do an unclaimed funds search for
your state search your name and check if
money is owed to you you're welcome I
did this before have you guys ever done
this I got like 80 bucks or something
I'm about to do it yeah something
happened with uh what happened was a
Bank closed and I had like 20 bucks in
the account so the money didn't go
anywhere and then somehow it ended up
with the state the state had my name on
it and said you can claim it you got to
put in your information and then they
mailed me the check and I was like what
but it was like it was like two or three
different checks there was one where it
was like an unclaimed tax refund or
something that I never knew about yeah
someone told me to go look for it and
then I was like wow I won't be surprised
if I go there right now actually
and I find that I got a bunch of money
it'll be worth it tea party Geezer says
Vivek ramaswamy is co-founder of strive
Asset Management what did you say to
search for unclaimed unclaimed funds
yeah unclaimed funds is everyone doing
it right now search for your state
unclaimed funds I got too many states to
search
usa.gov money and credit how to find
unclaimed money well it seems like a
great way to get your identity
current information what do they want
why do they want them social security
number please
you can also so I looked up Maryland
it's like buy unclaimed property it's
like oh okay I've heard stories I think
NPR ran a story a long time ago about a
a homeless man who basically created a
business doing this for people like
looking up where their money was from
and then people would be like well okay
like you're giving me a hundred dollars
I'll give you five just for doing that
and this this is like one of the ways
his side hustle I can't remember where
this story goes other than the fact that
he did this I don't know what happened
to him it's the end of my anecdote
Justin G says I can't wait for the
aliens aren't real conspiracy theories
to start once the government says
they're real
now we're at the point where like Joe
Rogan is gonna be in his show and he's
gonna be like yeah dude I just don't
think that aliens are real because the
government's always lying and then Daily
Beast is gonna be like conspiracy brain
Joe Rogan thinks the alien hearing was
fake I sometimes I feel like they want
to reclaim the word alien so people stop
saying illegal alien when they talk
about immigrants he doesn't believe in
the Roswell commission report
that Bob Lazar was full of it the whole
time
this
taking taking back toxic says aliens
would want nothing to do with humans
humans would do the naughty with their
kids and steal their stuff
there was some great memes that was like
the X-Files poster I want to believe it
was like I wanted to believe aliens are
real until the government said they were
yeah yeah
you have to wonder like the aliens are
so great why haven't they shown up by
now they don't need the US government's
permission and why is it always the U.S
this is never happening in other
countries it's always here that happened
in Brazil that time ago all right jatric
penifer says regarding Nibiru it
originates from Zechariah sitchin he
found the reference in ancient Sumerian
Tablets but only he could translate them
and he wouldn't let anyone else
corroborate his translations he was the
poster child Source trust me bro I'm
pretty sure you're talking about uh
Joseph Smith yeah it sounds like a
Joseph spread it on Golden Plates yeah
yeah but that may actually be true I
don't know I I've heard that name
Zechariah before yeah that is I think
there's a guy translated dude you know
the the the the early 2000s internet was
like the best thing ever yeah you'd just
find the craziest websites full of just
garbled insane nonsense it was just
awesome
posts I found some old website Denver
Airport back in the day and it's like
this really it's like Comic Sans and
just like it's got a Hulk Hogan and Jeff
dancing Papyrus sex yeah yeah all that
stuff good old days I like that the
Denver Airport has started at least on
Instagram acknowledging the Denver
Airport conspiracies because they just
get so many comments about it what do
they call the the horse
do you guys know the name uh Lucifer
Lucifer yeah
do they have do they do they turn that
into merch they could turn that into so
much Merchant and the horse killed the
guy who made it right yeah the artist
that made it and then he had finished
without him like questionable I think
the Denver Airport at least on Instagram
they have some really funny stuff about
being like well thank you guys for
stopping by but they they could lean
into it I think then
I feel like then they'd be like please
stop like we don't want to admit that
there's anything here my favorite was
that I guess there are a lot of
Chipotles in Denver and someone was like
oh well that's because you think it's
because it was founded here but actually
it's because they all ultimately have uh
underground tunnels where they store
extra rice and beans so when the elites
have to move into the Denver Airport
they'll have access to food I think this
that wouldn't make sense as to why they
sell the food to people they just sell
it as a front to continue to order tons
of supplies to put on I just I you know
it would be a fun show a show where all
of these conspiracy theories are real so
like Nibiru is real and there are aliens
that are coming to Earth because they
want gold but the Earth is flat it's
also Hollow so like there are deep
underground tunnels that go into a
hollow Earth and Earth is just this disc
like shell you know just all of them at
once
that'd be great and the the way you get
into the center of the earth is through
the North Pole there's a hole there
apparently where Santa hangs out and
guards it yeah
I think this is a good idea you actually
like Hollow Earth just it's a fun
conspiracy just because it's like low
earth yeah I I don't believe it but it's
just as a friggin conspiracy for me it's
like it's not a conspiracy you know what
I mean yeah I guess technically it's
what you call it yeah I don't know what
you'd call it I mean I guess technically
people would have to conspire to keep
that secret so I guess you kind of by a
technical Fringe Theory
that's a different the conspiracy theory
that would be the government keeping a
secret about Hollow Earth when the idea
of the earth could be Hollow maybe no
one even knows I mean there's a lot to
the operation high jump story too if
people want to dig into it but was that
during was that in the 1800s or
something no I think it was uh what like
World War II roughly isn't high jump
like the Nazi one where they live they
have a place on the moon no it's on the
uh
South Pole yeah there are was a legit
operation that occurred there but it's
like people spiral out different
theories from what happened because they
came back because they had that place on
an alert in Canada oh yeah 1946. yeah
it's wild it's a crazy story yeah so
establish the Antarctic research base
Little America four
oh yeah yeah a lot of people go go into
Hollow Earth with that one like oh he
found Hollow Earth he found the entrance
I see yeah
would you go in to Hollow Earth I would
go in yeah
they don't like humans so how do you
know yeah what if they're not aliens
what if the UFOs are like you know we we
build these submarines and go down to
the water what if there's just like
Hollow Earth denizens that create ships
to come up and like explore the surface
and could you imagine how shocking it
would be if you lived inside this big
sphere this big dome with like some kind
of energy source in the middle or
whatever and then you're like how could
anything possibly survive outside of
this it's like there's nothing there and
then they finally go on an expedition
and they say people and they're like
they go back in and they tell everybody
there are people on the outside of this
and they're like that's impossible they
fall off there's no way you crazy
conspiracy theorists
conspiracies
Captain Von Erich says anything Trump
might have done versus State Governor is
giving the okay to non-american policing
Americans which is worse
yeah
certainly certainly Leon Yoda's
Republicans are honorable people and
they want to play by the rules but as
Carpe dongtum uh axed today you cannot
compromise your way into a winning
position against an opponent who doesn't
value compromise or fair play ever that
is correct I hate this verb X I just
want that on record tweet is better why
don't you ask about it I will not so
it's like repost now rather than retweet
I love that I hate it why aren't we
ruining something they still won't
change the Twitter movies account what
yeah yeah because it can't be x movies
yeah
[Laughter]
and also Twitter spaces are X spaces now
not to be confused
this doesn't like Elon what are we doing
I'm so masterful it's brilliant he just
recycles the logo and just turns the
line I do like this thing where he's
like you're all gonna comply like he
could have been like oh his Twitter acts
and then like slowly rolled it out but
instead he was like it's X and you all
have to deal with it I like it this way
yeah I had to have a conversation with
my wife that like hey you're about to
see a bill on that says X I want you to
be clear what this is please do not be
concerned
oh man I hope that lots of husbands have
had that conversation it took a while to
Dawn me I was like
all right James Richard says Congress
has the power to coin money the Federal
Reserve is a private company not only is
that fraud against but against the
Constitution if it's not Congress
coining money then Congress has no
liability
oh well
Samurai says is this the same lizzo that
played Madison's flute correct the one
and only lizzo
we are we are not pleased all right what
do we got a green Clover says
yesterday's show is the first I missed
in a while live and you talked about
drones you've been doing for 10 years
yeah we talked about uh uh the Drone in
drone stuff in Moscow
yeah crazy stuff man and it's only going
to get crazier because they're cheaper
and cheaper to produce and uh very scary
yeah
sanay says there was a huge Monopoly in
the light bulb industry the owners of
these companies all came together and
agreed to make light bulbs that didn't
last long look into it it's crazy messed
up I've heard the story apparently the
first light bulb ever made has been on
forever and it's in a firehouse in New
York City yeah and then they were just
like yeah but if we sell these everyone
will just have them so what do we do and
then I was reading like these the woke
people came out and said did you know
the light bulb was actually invented by
a black man yeah and uh it's because the
filament used in the light bulb was made
by a black scientist who never received
credit and then I was like wait are you
talking about the the planned
obsolescence like the light bulbs that
were intended to fail he invented
because now I'm kind of like you don't
want to take credit for that one yeah
that's not I feel like that's not as
cool as you think it is it's like the
guy who invented the Super Soaker
finally got credit like 20 years later
yeah that doesn't have planned
obsolescence does it I don't know it's a
fun fact Ryan Bircher says GE closed its
last incandescent bulb operation a few
years ago it was in Winchester Virginia
oh really right up the road from Tim and
cost a number of local jobs yeah we hang
on Winchester all the time super close
like I don't know it's like 45 minutes
or something at the most yeah they have
a good Mexican restaurant yeah and I
love their old downtown yeah they have
like a retro gaming place I bought a
bunch of video games from like Nintendo
it's a good spot and I love the library
though the Hanley library is gorgeous
Mojave says unequivocally Bears built
Stonehenge seriously maybe with the
alcubier warp drive utilizing vacuum
flux faster than light travel could be
possible uh Stonehenge was collapsed and
then they like people rebuilt it yeah
they were like let's make this a thing I
like we think that's what it's like
conspiracies or Fringe theories that
bring in Bears I feel like we should
give Bears more to do they should have a
bigger starring role in all of our
narratives I feel like that's fun it
would be fun
wood
you heard it here first would be it
would be no that was a bit from Norm
Macdonald he was like Twas you're you're
shortening it was it's not even that
hard to say twas that's a good one Twas
the Night Before Christmas
what do we have RB play says what do you
believe will happen if they actually put
Trump in prison I believe it might be
Chaos on a level we've never seen before
I don't think Trump supporters go out
and start smashing and writing no I
think that putting Trump in pit in
prison destabilizes the market in such a
way that it causes crisis in people's
401ks and pension inflation would be out
of control and they'd have to
desperately try to to clamp it down but
the uncertainty of of putting Trump in
prison on the elections would make
investors panic and leave and go invest
in something else with bricks now making
their big announcement about expansion
and their gold-backed currency it's the
stupidest thing imaginable you could do
and then when that happens people will
write over not having food sorry also am
I missing something if if they put Trump
in prison would they also have to
station it with a bunch of Secret
Service agents like how would they do
that how could they actually I don't
know facilitate having him in prison
that's why it seems like for whatever
reason the only
space that fits for the puzzle pieces
Trump wins the president wins 2024.
because I I don't I don't I don't know
how the system survives can you imagine
there's a secret service agent that has
to go to prison what's wrong they just
rotate out to new guy every night I mean
it's not going to work yeah yeah but
like then you have to go in and out of
the prison system like instead of being
like oh we're traveling we're doing
whatever it's like the worst when I went
to become a secret service agent I never
thought I'd have to eat prison food I
thought I'd be just hanging out in
Delaware with Joe Biden but he would go
to a minimum security prison where he'd
wear a polo and khakis and golf all day
I feel like he wouldn't go to prison I
feel like that's no right it's not going
to happen be like on house arrest from
Mar-A-Lago with the internet for the
rest of his life it would destabilize
the US economy in a way they they would
wouldn't predict could not predict I
also think it would make a lot of people
that are kind of on the fence about it
that don't necessarily believe Trump is
this evil person and if you don't vote
for him we're gonna be like this is
insane like this is it's like Jumping
the Shark you know all right one more
Super Chat Marshall paulikan says you
just described the show and inside job
on Netflix first of all that show was
canceled second of all it was a very
poorly written comedy that had only like
one funny joke that I liked and it's
where the mushroom guy from Hollow Earth
said that he was doing drugs with Joe
Rogan but couldn't handle it or
something like that but I'm talking
about a serious Game of Thrones style
show where they're all real but anyway
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends take that URL posted everywhere
because that's the best way to help word
of mouth is how podcasts grow and uh
head over to timcast.com click join us
to become a member to support our work
directly and then you will get access to
our members only uncensored show which
is coming up in just a few minutes where
I'm going to write a song and then we'll
talk about things and stuff and you will
call into the show as a member and we'll
answer questions so you can smash the
like button you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast Jose do you want to shout
anything out sure uh go follow my show
I'm on no way Jose I'm on YouTube all
the major art projectors Odyssey as well
uh and Rumble now uh and then also if
you want to actually look into the OKC
bombing go check out Liberty and
libertarianinstitute.com or dot org my
bad slash OKC uh that's the largest
public Archive of all Oklahoma City
Bombing related documents so if you want
to do your own research that's the place
to do it or you can check out my series
if you want it served up to you on a
platter uh but I highly recommend that
uh and yeah follow me on Twitter at
targeting Jose cool thanks for being on
tonight uh I'm Hannah Claire brimo I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should follow
at timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
uh I think I may have an opt-out out
this week I don't know and Chris
bertman's covering Andy knows trial so
definitely things to check out uh if you
want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at hannahclar.b and on Twitter
at HC brimlow thank you so much all
right guys if you'd like to follow me
Instagram and X I guess not Twitter at
Brett dasovic on both of those platforms
pop culture crisis Monday through Friday
3 P.M Eastern Standard Time that is noon
Pacific Amazon music Apple podcast
Pandora and Spotify if you'd like to
listen to it thanks
Jose always a pleasure to have you here
man yeah I feel rude thanks for having
me guys no no worries not at all uh yeah
it's uh it's been a fun show pleasure to
have you out here too Brad never see you
all the time here but uh yeah I am
search.com uh I guess
X or whatever Instagram I hate saying X2
it's just it just makes no sense uh yeah
let's see in the after show we'll see
you all over at timcast.com in just a
few minutes thanks for hanging out